the hacker known as 4chan has apparently
cracked hunter biden's icloud account
and uh is leaking a bunch of
incriminating photos stories texts
and boy this one's a doozy now i know
everybody's excited about these images
of hunter biden no one's really excited
about them i'm kidding but excited about
the political implications of them what
i'm really concerned about is what we're
going to get in terms of inner family
trauma
the name that hunter biden allegedly
uses for his own father referring to him
as a child abuser it's very strange and
whether or not we're going to be able to
verify this information is true and
correct now the interesting thing is a
report from the washington examiner
is lending some credibility to the leak
saying that some of this information is
corroborated in a previous
data breach from hunter's iphone so it
could just be that someone new has
gotten access to the iphone backup but
what they're saying is it's the actual
icloud which is current information from
hunter but apparently the secret service
is aware of this things are getting
absolutely crazy so we got to talk about
it because we also got to make sure
we're careful some of this stuff coming
out could very well be fake we got to
break it down talk about it so we will
we also have another story just about
hunter apparently he's potentially on
the hook for trafficking ladies of the
night across state lines we try to keep
things family friendly here it's
insane joe biden's approval ratings in
the gutter and then i'm really excited
for this next story new york city you
know i am new york city put out a psa on
how to survive a nuclear strike
so uh okay why
sure i guess the cold war is back we
will be talking about all that but
before we do my friends head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com
to pick up your keto elevate c8mct oil
powder you may have noticed and i
actually you know in all seriousness
around november i started cutting out
sugar i started i actually started
eating this put by eating it i put it in
my coffee i started having doing more
fat less sugar less grains i have lost
as of today about 30 pounds no joke it's
crazy that's like it's like might as
well do one of those before and after
photos but i lost a lot of weight and
i've been doing it through um started
with heavy keto and then moved into just
like low carb so definitely check out
eatrightandfeelwell.com for biotrust if
you're interested in something similar
you'll get a 60-day money-back guarantee
keto elevate provides your body only c8
the most ketogenic mct that's medium
chain triglycerides it's healthy fats
five grain grams of the salt highly
sought after mctc8 keto elevate i like i
like how they write this is my favorite
it really is and i mean this we had
someone else who had brought in some
other mct stuff and i actually didn't
like it this is great you're mixing your
coffee it's really really good you'll
get free shipping on every order and for
every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help them hit their
goal of 6 million meals this year you'll
get free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their free e-report
the top 14 ketogenic foods with every
order again head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com but don't forget
to head over also to timcast.com
become a member we've got major
announcements coming up soon we've got a
couple new shows we're launching tales
from the inverted world we have expanded
the production we were it was like a 10
minute free youtube show now it's going
to be a 40 minute to an hour long
exclusive show on our upcoming streaming
service apps are coming soon with your
support we are going to um i'd say in a
few years be bigger than disney and
netflix and all that stuff we have big
dreams here you'll also be supporting
our journalists and you'll get access to
our after hours show where um you know
we've got dave landau here and he's
really funny but he's restrained by the
youtube censorship but i'm really
excited for the after show because then
he won't be ahoy yes
yes yeah that's true i'm going to try to
talk about hunter biden in a classy
fashion
good luck yes so uh sign up at
timecast.com smash that like button uh
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and of course as i
already mentioned we got dave here he's
hanging out how's it going man good man
how about you i'm doing really well this
is great i'm happy to be here thank you
for having me for those uh apparently
everybody knows who you are but for
those that don't know you do you want to
introduce yourself yeah um i'm on uh
loud with crowder which is a television
radio thing
i like to sell myself well
uh it's uh every day i guess monday
through thursday we're not on right now
so i guess it's not on every day so i
was wrong in what i just said you can
check me out at davelando.com this week
and i'll be at the columbus funny bone
i'm a stand-up comic and uh yeah that's
about it right on we also brought in
jamie kilstein because we needed to make
this episode as funny as possible yeah
i'm another comedian you can tell that
dave and i are good comedians because we
hate ourselves and are not good at
promoting ourselves um i will be at the
slightly uh less nice dayton funny bone
i believe in august i'm there in august
as well oh hell yeah uh i'm gonna be
performing uh stand-up comedy in houston
dayton austin and los angeles uh all the
info is
appear if you follow me on social media
at twitter.com jamiekilstein or you can
follow me on instagram at the jamie kill
scene and i'm also now
officially the head writer and director
of cast castle on youtube
all the weird stories i've so far been
slapped by an employee tulsi gabbard
beat me in arm wrestling i accidentally
went on a date with james o'keefe we're
turning the vlog into essentially a show
about the comedy show about the culture
war so if you aren't already subscribed
you can go to youtube.comcastcastle
we have big dreams and maybe it's
arrogant to say but we're thinking like
a an office 30 rock style vibe but on
culture war issues would be really funny
so we're going to try we're going to
make it work and i think we're we're
doing so uh so far so good so i like it
yeah we got in not officially a comedian
unfortunately here to tickle your funny
bone nonetheless that's why you're happy
yeah
love life love every moment of it
get out of yeah the worst people
i just love every second of everything
you're gonna stretch fix your posture oh
no
they always die young oh my goodness
all right everybody's a gift
this is gonna be great i can tell
already i like the competition between
our two comedians here it's gonna be
hilarious evening thank you all for
joining ahoy i'm told i'm supposed to
say so let's get this show on the road
uh we have the story from the washington
examiner
it is not a funny story well actually
maybe it is kind of funny
4chan users claim to have cracked hunter
biden's iphone account and also
we have another story that's in a
similar thing secret service is aware of
alleged hunter but an icloud hack so it
says icloud
and it's his iphone
oh man this is getting crazy also is do
they use the word cracked as a mean play
on words perhaps or leaving his first
laptop at 15 different places
they could have said hack they could
have said they could have said hacked
into they said crap they sure did
okay so one of the videos
it shows to start hunter biden's face
from the front-facing camera and then
all of a sudden it flips to his feet
like he pressed record with the
front-facing camera and then press the
button and then it shows crack on a
scale yeah no no i i got to say this
it could be edited i don't know sure
someone could easily take a video of him
doing a selfie thing and then make a
fake but i kind of believe it because
hunter biden is a crackhead yes also i
know everyone's talking about the crack
thing but if wikifeet hasn't jumped on
the 100 item page get on it
there's so many pictures of him naked
he's also a guy who never got sober in
my opinion they just made him look like
it so he could do the tape the today
show yeah like they just grabbed him one
day fixed his teeth and he was like yeah
i did a lot of parmesan cheese off the
carpet
it's like no you didn't because crack is
cracking parmesan cheese is parmesan
cheese you're just making up a sobriety
story they did a sobriety weekend at
bernie's for essentially yeah did you
see the crack though like that's what
the taxpayers are paying for it's high
quality
it's like the only fentanyl-free crack
in the united states right now is at his
house and you can hear them arguing
about the weight of it in the background
of the video it sounds like hunter's
voice the girl's going it's it's 20.7
he's like it's 20.6
like you can get back i'm like you
couldn't buy points man and he's
slightly disappointed that he's like
not only he's a cracker but he's very
frugal yeah responsible yes
when it comes to crack that is people
are very very on point with the numbers
well i mean
if if movies tell us anything you know
hey this isn't weight you know the right
amount or whatever so look here let me
pull this up
the examiner actually says
many of the materials posted by 4chan
users match the contents the washington
examiner previously found on a
password-protected iphone xs backup
located on a copy of hunter biden's
abandoned laptop
konstantinos gus dimitrolos
i'm not going to read everything say but
he's a cyber security expert basically
says definitively this is real this
iphone backup he said i conclude the
same results in my now so the macbook
that it's uh it's real blah blah it is
was his his iphone now like it's one
expert opinion but we're getting there
yeah i say take it with a grain of salt
because i wouldn't be surprised if
somebody makes some fake screenshot of
text messages gets everybody to go nuts
then the media will come out and be like
proven false definitively and then try
and use it to discredit ignore
everything else yeah and i i just want
to say too that i think when we're
laughing at hunter biden addiction
sucks and is horrible and i've dealt
with addiction and i've dealt with in my
family and it's really sad and
depressing but i think that when we see
elites like this getting away with
things that your average person would be
completely shut down for arrested for
that's where it gets frustrating i got
it we got a fact check already it was
meth not crack
really
on the scale well you know then now he's
partying i feel stupid i know i feel
stupid i feel stupid though because when
i looked at it i thought it was meth and
not crack
but i'm not an expert on these things
see that's how and i'm a recovering drug
addict and elky but i never did meth
there was only one that i never did and
crack
i was surprised with have you taken mdma
oh yeah it's technically a type of meth
yeah is it oh well
yeah then i haven't done that that's
cool yeah but there's like a crystal
which is right it's with black tarpon
it's the fun method i've done the no
i've not done that i should be specific
i've not done the trailer park math i've
done the aids patient
i've heard rough stuff about crystal i
know kids people listening out there oh
i'm sorry you don't want to be like
no no no no no no nobody wants to be
like
i saw a video of joe biden and it looked
like he was in front of congress like i
made the law that if you get caught with
this much you're going to jail for five
years and a judge can't even oh my
sister was juxtapositioned with just
doing hunter doing all of it i i just
want to say to all the you know the
younger people who may be listening yeah
because this show is not for kids but
maybe your parents you need to
understand
you don't do drugs no because then all
the other kids will mock you and call
you hunter biden that's like the worst
possible thing again it's bad yeah
that's real bad you could be so popular
you do have to discern what the word
drug means because aspirin is a drug
black tar heroin is a drug that's right
don't do black tar health don't do black
pepper and ask your parents yes i yeah
there's no black tar heroin with the
word kids written under no
it looks like a flintstone vitamin d
wait wait hold on there was a
libertarian confession
you know this one right no i'm just
laughing at the setup true it's true
where uh was it austin peterson who said
don't sell her the kids and they booed
him
it's like can we at least agree there's
a line there no no
all right
did you say at the beginning that the
secret service put out a statement
saying that his we have that let me let
me just cloud it so so this is these are
two different stories but they overlap
so uh secret service says it's aware of
alleged hunter by an icloud hack quote
at this time we are not in a position to
make public comments on potential
investigative actions
okay so 4chan says they cracked the
phone now we have the icloud the
difference is
the iphone backup was apparently on the
laptop so you know you know when you
when you plug your iphone in it's like
back it up it's on your computer and
then someone finds it they gotta get the
code for it you do now yeah with uh the
icloud apparently it says current icloud
meaning stuff you were sending a week
ago or whatever yeah the crazy thing is
now this stuff needs to be verified but
if it's true
and the icloud stuff we we we got to get
verification on
yo he calls his dad
he calls his dad um
a person who abuses children i'll keep
it family friendly
his nickname in his phone is
you know now look we've all said mean
things to our dad in our worst faces
right this one's a little i've never
insinuated that either of my parents
were like child abusers before that's a
big kind of weird there's also uh
alleged search history for
underage underage is an understatement
like as underage as underage could
probably get really pre-medicine do you
think that's why i'm saying it's got we
got to verify this because yeah you
can't just say yeah i mean but maybe he
saw all the videos that we've saw for
the last four years of him sniffing kids
he was like oh this
[Laughter]
did you ever see that there was a family
guy joke where there's a murderer in
prison yeah and then he's like i wonder
what this feels like and he stabs up
some stabs himself and he goes whoa is
that what i'm doing to people
that's what it's like joe biden has
never actually watched the video of him
sniffing these children
reiterate what you said addiction is
horrific yes but that that the media has
been a lot of the media has been like
silent on this and hasn't even like
possibly maybe hunted by now as a
problem is what i'm laughing about it's
insane it's complete insanity yeah and
it's like the fact that he can totally
get away with it and we've just been
locking up black people indiscriminately
for like crack since like the 80s
we don't have to have a problem with
everything but my point
is no i'm with you like i'm i'm a
recovering addict so we make fun of it
in let's say these meetings i go to or
speeches that i do i make fun of myself
you do make fun of it it's not
necessarily fun to just punch at
somebody's addiction but we are paying
for this addiction i mean there's a lot
that goes in and the media like you said
has been hiding it this entire time i
think we're allowed to make fun of it
when we've been funding it and look at
what they've been doing to the other
side's kids i mean they've been calling
trump's kid a cokehead for what five six
years now yeah i don't like making fun
of people suffering from addiction i
don't either i've had more than one
friend die from heroin overdose
what i'm making fun of is the fact the
president's son is protected by the
media
unwell
uh his father is funding a lot of the
stuff but more importantly
that
okay so some of the allegations here we
we've seen reports okay so this is
confirmed from the laptop that hunter
shares a phone number with his dad
weird now in these leaks there is a text
message from hunter to his dad of him
engaging in let's just call it adult
activities and again a legend because we
don't know this stuff is true or not my
dad didn't even teach me how to shave
i'm almost jealous
but we do know from the laptop so so the
photo of hunter getting it on to his dad
might not be real the text yeah but we
do know there's a text from him to his
dad of pornhub that was from the laptop
and that was reported by a couple
different outlets so why would you send
your dad that information bonding so
look i don't look king
joe's dad i found a great video
real quick though so my concern here is
look i don't i don't want to make fun of
the guy for being sick no what i want to
call out is
hunter may be doing business as his dad
with his dad's permission right if he's
using a phone number under his dad's
name
sending these links he's probably who's
he really sending them to is it
it may be his dad i mean he calls his
dad it's just okay allegedly he calls
his dad pedo
in the in so again not verified what a
clever nickname clever yes no one would
would suspect it not a man of metaphor
would you take out the d
wink
i think
hunter and joe
are using the father-son relationship so
that hunter can do the business dealings
that joe can't yes yes but it's
effectively joe doing the deals yeah
i think so too i mean even in uh the
book uh oh i'm blanking on the name of
it laptop from hell i mean that's kind
of what it's alluded to anyway why would
you pick your most unstable son to do
all the shady business because your
other one's dead
seriously seriously you're you're giving
all the shady jobs to the kid whose
password i'm sure is give me more crack
one two three four it's like how do you
hack it but joe's password is wrong kid
the alleged password was um
it was something really bad too really
yeah
it was a reference to the age of a woman
so allegedly yeah yeah i don't know how
is it good but i i looked at some of the
claims and accusations it's a lot of a
lot of outlets are picking up the
accusations and they're all saying like
this could be fake but apparently the
password was
uh uh i don't want to say it because
it's not my business but it was it was
like the password was a woman and her
age
really like
but yeah unless it was a the number was
a reference something else was it at
least double digits it was good
and and it was at least post-pubescent
yeah that's good that's great that's
good my man's growing up it's possible
that this is a setup like because it
makes him look very deviant and it makes
joe look like he said pito peter
whatever the name he had for his dad
and he's got his password as like a
young girl like that is it's not it's
beyond the detail adult age it's an okay
but a young adult i guess yeah like like
like the drug addiction stuff i see what
you're saying where it's almost a little
too on the nose
um
it's very it's so bizarre but he left
his laptop like he left it somewhere
i just wanted three of them i want all
of you to know yeah what i sacrifice for
all of you
i want you to know this so become a
member at teamcast.com because i had to
look at all of these photos of naked
hunter
confirm
i'm like looking at these stories and
i'm like i i have to i have to be there
because if people are claiming it's
there and i'm not doing my due diligence
so yeah ten dollars a month there i had
to do it a bunch too yeah
i'm gonna have to do it later tonight
hold on we're gonna need to take a break
and i'll do it right now i'm pretty sure
the daily caller published an uncensored
image of hunter biden holding himself oh
no but because he was partially
underwater
the water kind of obfuscated it and i
was like did they think you couldn't see
what he was doing because you can yeah
yeah i think it was the caller touching
his dad's leg
hair when he was talking about the kids
rubbing his hairy legs he was referring
to his own children oh no
in all seriousness i'll say it again i
think joe abused his kids yes yeah i do
yeah hands down i think
so the reason why hunter's so screwed up
why does hunter call his dad allegedly
call his dad pedo if he really does this
and that is true
that combined with everything else we
know i think joe
sniffed his son a little bit i've heard
that ashley biden's diary now this is
like a thing i don't know if it's real
or fake or what but i've i've been
reading stuff about it that she also
implicates her dad in this spot in this
diary i have never seen the diary i
don't know if it's real or not no i've
heard the same thing though
i think you might be right
he looks like gary oldman in hannibal
have you noticed that that's kind of
what joe biden is turning into just this
monster
yeah like if you look at him in hannibal
like he just looks like that and i
really do think it's all his secrets
just coming into age
yeah like he looks like him it's really
and the more he talks because now like
especially in the top right
top right you tell me that's not joe
yeah
that is totally joe
yeah
look at the tie oh and the tie for sure
the pigs will eat anything yeah
oh yeah yeah that guy came right a
bicycle
no he's falling right off a bike
i thought it was going to be an image
it's him after falling
can we we should get this one i thought
it was going to be a picture of gary
oldman
not some disfigured you know no no mason
burger i'm wonderful a lot of people
watching were just like yo i'm trying to
eat yeah yeah sorry if you were trying
to but it looks just like the
president's it's fine he got all that
face work done yeah he really did you
see the uh uh when he said end of quote
repeat the line oh it's the best it was
the ice i called it guys i called it the
white house in the transcript
wrote let me repeat that line yeah all
right let me repeat the line
oh so they changed the characters in the
transcript they changed what he said
yeah because they're trying to cover it
up i remember when government meant
integrity no no i thought it did i swear
if they show the podium it's just gonna
be one of those things where you pull
and it's like the cow says move yeah
it's just
like it's in it when like the salute the
troops thing it goes right back to that
where it's like say salute the troops
he's like salute the troops or he's like
instead of saluting
them ever see like the animatronic
you know uh chuck e cheese things
playing guitar yes like that's what joe
biden is yes oh yeah behind him it's all
exposed metal in like yeah
just turns him on he's just playing the
piano
i love how he actually said end of quote
repeat the line yeah and he's like end
of quote repeat the line and then the
same quote plays and it's like
anybody who's sane saw that and laughed
like i know people who are like democrat
liberal leftists everybody was like it's
so it's so dumb we know joe biden's out
of it only 26 of democrats think he
should run again they're under no
illusions this man is capable they'll
they'll take something else but the
media is still trying to pretend like
anyone is falling for it i guess 26 of
the democrat voters are they're really
pretending yeah we're really pretending
i was a little surprised greg price
posted that quote and it got a lot of
traction and i noticed that the top one
of the first comments you see is one of
the white house aides saying that's not
what he actually said and giving her
version of it which is the version that
ended up being in the transcript
the people that are still so
blindly tied to biden are inferior like
when i posted that stuff of me and tulsi
i had a friend reach out to me just
unloading uh tulsi's the reason that roe
v wade got over to it it's like it's
like it's like the people who still
blame susan sarandon if it wasn't for
susan sarandon and it's like guys if an
actress if an old lady actress can
derail your political party your
political party sucks period if you are
still blaming tulsi gabbard who's
literally not in office right now i did
a comedy sketch with my friend and
you're unloading on her instead of i
don't know the president of the united
states who actually has power right now
like there are still people on the left
who are so in denial and just refuse to
hold biden accountable for some reason
when biden isn't giving them even
anything they want but they're
technically right tulsi broke a lot of
people out of the cult
she she went up and she uh she
represented much of what the left was in
this country especially during the late
2000s early 2010s actually anti-war
actually anti-war actually calling out
the machine
she's got some policy positions that
conservatives wouldn't agree with she
was pro-choice traditionally like safe
legal rare she was for gun control she
opposed nuclear power i don't know where
she is on those things now yeah but
that's like the traditional democrat
position
with the weird movements the democratic
parties made to try and pander to
whatever it is they're trying to pander
to she stayed where she was yep she said
kamal is awful what are you doing yeah
and the machine got angry with her
because they were trying to move in some
weird direction which by the way the
reason she was calling out kamala was
actually from the left about some of the
horrible stuff kamala did in california
to poor communities enslaving people
yeah
yeah not a not a great one like actually
keeping people in prison longer so she
can use them for cheap firefighter labor
yeah but it was for dimebag so it's cool
yeah yeah right yeah it all made sense
she's a good person so yeah so i'll so
i'll hope she's president this is why
your friend
that's why you might get your wish here
in the next couple of years the next
five minutes
this is why your friend's manager
doesn't eat soup yeah not because
tulsa is a russian asset but because
the people who want to maintain the cult
don't like it don't like apostates right
you've seen like
the scientologists react to people that
try to leave the scientists there's a
what was the girl rogan he did a long
interview with her was it it wasn't leah
romini
yeah yeah yeah just tell all what her
experience in the cult and out of the
cult and the way that they chased her
down i mean they would literally chase
people to stop them from leaving the
physical location imagine what they
would do mentally if they're willing to
physically try and stop someone from
leaving the building right like that's
that's just guys we have to jump to is
this br massive very very important
story here oh boy from the daily mail
exclusive
hunter biden could face prostitution
charges for transporting
hookers
across state lines and disguising checks
to them as payment for medical services
well i mean that's a medical it's a
medical center in many ways no
it's a mental health service it's a
medical service it's a prostate milk
yeah there you go yes
for 30 000 in five months on the
girlfriend experience warning graphic
content i'm not going to show you the
actual images but so this is this is
actually outside of the icloud hack and
the phone hack apparently the feds have
known that he did this since 2019 of
course so there's
is anything really going to happen of
course not these people are as corrupt
as corrupt can be but now that we know
do you think it's going to change
anybody's mind
i should have stressed this real quick a
suspicious activity report filed by
jpmorgan chase flagged transactions
involving moriva after she received tens
of thousands of dollars from hunter's
company so it was actually chase bank
that was like something
with this and flagged it suspicious
activity uh i don't think anybody who
knows anything about the bidens is
surprised by any of this and i don't
think anybody believes there will be any
accountability or justice well i don't
know this was this is one where like
when you're talking about prostitution
people in the the cult everybody their
ears perk up and if this is actually
there's evidence that he did this and
and wasted i don't know if his taxpayer
money or whatever this world is pretty
much i think it's i think it's actually
essentially fraud
maybe so look it's one thing for
prostitution but when you're bringing
them to different states that's when i
say i've had enough well but i i was
actually seriously gonna ask that
because i that's actually a huge huge
the libertarian uh part of me i think
that uh prostitution should be illegal i
think that drug should be legal but why
are you take why are you shuffling
ladies of the night across the state
like why
why are you doing that what was it
boston in new york no but i actually
don't know like why why would you take
them across state lines
but hold up it's not like if you need a
like an umbrella it'll be there when you
get there yeah just get in the trunk
when you arrive i think this dude is
deeply disturbed and was abused and he's
he's like he's trying to emulate the
girlfriend experience sex drug addict
right right right right he's just he
wants people to pretend like they care
about him man it's brutal well yeah the
girlfriend experience is basically it is
broken down to the fact like it's not
the girlfriend experience of like two
years in where you're fighting right he
just wants to be like that would be a
real bummer of a 30 000 yeah you spend
it and you're just arguing about
groceries like you stay at a hotel
there's all your stuff's on the lawn
well
but but you're right though that's what
it's about i mean it comes into the fact
that he was unloved as a child somebody
completely broke and hurt him and that's
what this comes down to i really believe
unloved as a child yeah well
no but even both
even if he was even if he wasn't abused
i think
what you're saying is just that form of
abandonment which probably happens a lot
with powerful parents like that you
would still it would still make sense
that you're reaching for drugs sex and
love addiction you know the only time
joe biden hugged his son was to sniff
him right seriously yeah
or to push him out of the way to hug his
brother
he really was awful too hunter just
keeps putting on like pretty perfume to
get his dad to come sniff him and get
yeah he's wearing a girl's wig
his dad apparently funds all this stuff
like there's another story where hunt
like this is this crazy thing uh the
bots really came out in force i tweeted
how is the media going to ignore all
these photos is that insane like the
photos that i have seen will give me
nightmares for the rest of us i have
ptsd right
i need their i'm kidding yeah but it's
like they're really awful photos and
videos and all of a sudden i get
inundated by weirdos defending hunter
bite and i'm like this is weird why
would anyone defend hundred you have to
you don't have to like democrats to be
to be like like you can just stay quiet
you know or you you can say like i voted
for biden and i think this is really bad
because it is yes it's it's so weird of
course but the the defenses are weird
they're like hunter's not even a public
figure who cares and i'm like he flew on
air force two with his dad to do a
private equity deal with china and
secured the deal and now
uh joe biden has reportedly sold nearly
a million barrels of our crude to
sinopac a chinese-owned gas company that
hunter biden has uh his
private equity firm he founded
co-founded has purchased 1.7 billion in
10 epic marketing so it's like yeah if
hunter was just in like a journey cover
band in des moines it would be fine but
he is involved in this stuff and this
has been since right after he left
office as the vice president i mean this
has all been happening since then it's
actually interesting because his
lifestyle is more in line with the
journey journey
you know we can actually save hunter
right now join a journey cover band and
this will all go away really more in
line with like the ex-drummer of a
really great band
i'm looking at the uh the trauma
in 1972 he was in a car accident with
his brother who was he was like two at
the time and his mom was in the car and
his sister who both died his mom yeah
he's saying this interview with people
magazine that he didn't the family never
really talked about it so i can imagine
that being a source of like maddening
trauma if your dad never mentions brutal
yeah so rough i think it may have
something to do with
there's you know i don't know if it's
it's uh true or if it's just anecdotal
but my experience growing up is that the
kids in the suburbs who had wanted for
nothing did tons of drugs oh yeah
absolutely it was easy to fall into that
free time they were bored so for me in
detroit some of the richest kid i knew
the richest kids i knew they got
everything they wanted and didn't
appreciate anything they had no purpose
a lot of them are dead now yeah i i
forgot about this story until we started
i've been also triggered by hunter biden
uh i smoked crack once by accident where
it was with this rich kid who would come
to our house sometimes and i was just a
weed guy i never did hard drugs and
we're smoking it was bunter hiding
bunter hiding
what was that simpsons uh l simpson no
no that's too obvious lisa s
um the
uh
and i was smoking and i was like yeah i
feel kind of weird man and he looks at
me and again this was like the rich kid
and he looks at me and just goes oh yeah
there may be a little crack in that and
i was like buddy there's no such thing
as a little crack you either smoked no
crack or you are now addicted to crack
and i was just like what is it and yeah
i did but yeah i was the pr we were
suburbs we were the poor kids in the
suburbs
but all the people who were doing hard
drugs were the rich kids in our area
yeah we were just smoking bad weed and
seeing fish legit though the scary thing
right now is the the lacing of drugs yes
oh the fen it's horrible fentanyl there
was like a tons of story i saw a story
was like an 18 year old kid thought he
was going to party and
he took in some fentanyl not realizing
that's what that yeah there were a
couple comics who died it was a big
story in like comedy community it was
like three of them in a house yeah i've
lost eight friends in two years
defending him
what's your take being in recovery on
um
like the strips to test because it's one
of those things where it's like we
shouldn't have to we obviously don't
want to encourage people to do drugs but
like i think it's a good idea you have
to remember the first time i thought i
was on a new york subway and i was like
oh that's nice you know test your drugs
for drugs right
and uh but yeah i think it's it's better
than nothing because now it's it's it's
put in there well it's put in there from
china given to mexican cartels put into
your stuff to make it more potent and
people say well why would you want to
kill your clientele it's like there's no
shortage of addiction
right you can make new ones every day
right but i also think that china's
intent is actually just the
destabilization and destruction of the
country 100 percent the opium wars are
still active right
what's the strip you're talking about
this drug detection strip uh it actually
tests your drink you can put it into
your cocaine it'll tell you if you're
spending wow it's just a piece of like a
strip that turns a color or something
yeah but you can you can miss it though
too because fentanyl is so little i mean
the tiniest amount right yeah
i i think we need to um do uh
drug abstinence abstinence only yes
that's correct
don't do drugs don't you yeah i agree
with you you gotta you gotta define the
word drug fentanyl is an insidious
dangerous chemical i mean i gotta be at
the beginning too like we're going
towards more military upgraded drugs
it's gonna be like buff out from fallout
you guys ever play like these crazy
psychoactive
strength inducing addictive things we
got to watch out for and they're just
making more and more in laboratories as
they do lasers bioshock is a better
better example stuff that twists your
dna and makes you like feral crazy i
mean yeah we need better drugs yeah
that's right well that's what i'm aiming
for yeah it's better
but like doctor prescribed better
functioning
no bad side effects no bodily
destruction or whatever even even not
what's used to peacefully put down
elephants
[Laughter]
even with psychedelics they're doing it
uh medically now it's you're with a
therapist and they're mdma treatments
ketamine treatments um even with
psilocybin and it's
helping for ptsd for depression but it
is not oh i'm doing mushrooms and going
to hooters with the boys on friday it is
literally you are sitting with a
therapist there taking notes it is look
look ibuprofen you can get over the
counter and it's fantastic i hurt my
back a couple weeks ago i couldn't even
move it was brutal and
took a bunch of them and it really
helped you wanna you still wanna be
careful with that stuff because that'll
rip your your muscles up against
yourself i get heartburn every time i
take it yeah yeah exactly it stops your
body from producing it like mucus or
whatever yeah so your stomach will
digest itself if you do too much of it
that's why it's like
yo you got to talk to a doctor no
yeah and uh non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories yeah it's it's
i get unless i i yeah i got heartburn
every i can't take like aspirin or advil
it like tears my stomach up yeah
everything created by man is to kill you
it's terrible it's the worst well no
it's just like it's just there's a
there's a you got you got you got to pay
you got to pay your dues yeah like if
you want the pain to go away there's a
there's a limit to how much you can
actually accommodate with with
anything yeah you know too much exercise
is bad for you you got you got a rest
days eating too much meat you get the
meat sweats you get sick you might barf
water electrolyte displacement building
technology to destroy or consume things
more efficiently like the fork the fork
is great at putting a dead animal's body
into your mouth yeah so the saw is
fantastic at killing a tree so that you
can make wood at wooden structures out
of it like
we're really uh we're really innovative
when it comes to destroying and we have
better ways to destroy we're better than
the beaver
oh yeah yeah and they're all right they
wreck stuff these are are good tear it
up good straight up never seen a damn
i'm like damn oh yeah
oh that's why they call them that i
think so yeah i think this is the first
one we saw so let's
let's do this let's let's take it to the
biden family before we get into the
nuclear war stuff we got this from uh
real clear politics average joe biden's
aggregate approval rating hit a new
record low today at 37.7 percent this is
the aggregate this is not one biased
poll this is all of them
and
new york times released a poll with
biden at 33
i mean even before he started screwing
up as president i remember
when the primaries were happening and i
was like there's no way no one's going
to vote for this guy this isn't
happening and then he just finally at
the number of who voted for him
they finally did accurate math yeah 37.7
do you think that if he came out and was
like okay everybody it's true hunter has
a problem i put him on here just laid it
all out i i sent him where he needs to
go that that it would make it worse for
him it would so he's lying so he has to
lie i would respect him he has a problem
we put him into treatment like i don't
know most people that's the wrong focal
point yeah that's why i'm like you know
i would i wouldn't be surprised if the
psyop is leaking these images of hunter
right to stop us from talking about
cynopec or or the the emails
the let's just say the business dealings
from hunter joe and hunter's business
partners the photographs
yeah all of a sudden everyone's like oh
look at hunter naked and it's like he's
got an email where he's talking about
you know
ten percent for the big guy and stuff
like that well i mean
it worked on me that was the joke i made
earlier where it's like why would you
make the delinquent kid in charge of all
this stuff so like if it is that it
worked
he put him on a board of an oil company
a ukrainian oil company well well he put
him there he didn't put him there let's
just say
the assumption would be
what we know is that hunter biden along
with i think like former c.i.a of course
was on the board of barisma yeah
uh joe biden
just so happened to um
push a quid pro quo with the president
of ukraine to fire a prosecutor who just
so happened to be investigating the
company whereas someone's a board member
it's all coincidence mind you because
joe said he didn't even talk to hunter
about any of his business dealings i
mean except for that one time they're in
a photo together with all of his
business partners and that other time
that he left a voicemail for his son
about his chinese business dealings yeah
tim god works in mysterious ways yeah
well yeah i mean it's also enron got a
new vp the last week and he was like wow
and i thought he'd be stuck in the mail
room all these years
that's good
so
i don't think here's a scary thought
joe biden what's that what's happening
now with the biden family with joe with
with gas with sending a million barrels
sign a pack that's really bad but will
it matter in two years
will people remember nah joe biden will
come out in it'll be two years and the
new cycle will be like joe biden farted
again mm-hmm
yeah and well in two years yeah that'll
be about it
i don't think he'll be able to do much
else they'll be like he
it's
almost a flat line
pretty much
i can't personally let go of the
surrender the afghanistan surrender that
one drives you nuts he left all this
eight billion dollars worth of equipment
i'm with you how many tens of thousands
of people to die with their babies like
to die to the taliban getting their
heads blown off like in in plain sight
of people that are right behind the wall
like watching it happen because he took
all the he he he evacuated and routed
the troop it's i think i think it was
punishment yeah but i think he was
punishing the anticipated look what a
bad choice trump made by saying we're
gonna be out on that day everyone see
what happens when you pull out on that
day but like you don't have to pull out
on the day you say you're gonna pull out
on if you're not ready you don't do it
right and so did obama i mean he said he
was to do that too and it's like when
you look at it he pulled it out and it's
like you left
military dogs alone made me angry but
then you left look at all the equipment
look at all the people that you left
behind that's what pissed me off about
all of it it's like then you come back
and you're going to start what having
the irs dig through a bunch of people's
taxes who legitimately paid make
arbitrary rules and start taking more
money from them while printing money
while you leave billions of dollars of
our equipment over there yeah like
everything about it makes me absolutely
sick yeah everytime's right about this i
think this is the perfect distraction
because you just pull all the attention
away from stuff that's actually
legitimately concerned absolutely like
afghanistan for one there's so many
other disasters going on right now and
all we're doing is talking about hunter
biden being a crackhead which and yeah
and again like in all seriousness i like
addiction is horrible could you could
you imagine that they're like
these like psyops people walk into the
situation room with uh with joe and it's
like this is really bad for you mr
president does afghanistan stuff what
can we do
and then like we have one proposal sir
we need to get hunter more crack he's
like
let's leak it to the press
one of hunters just is like great dude
desperately trying to get sober and he's
just like no i'm working on myself i
found buddhism i'm meditating and
they're just slipping him over and uh
your country needs you son and all of a
sudden uh okay then all of a sudden
hunter comes out from under the desk and
it's like i'm working on it
oh man if he wasn't if he wasn't put on
the board of barisma or if he didn't
make his way up to the board of barisma
somehow i wouldn't be concerned with his
activities i really wouldn't care no no
he's just a family
president yeah but that joe has been
working with them so intricately and and
the guys you know
naked with prostitutes do we do we have
to worry about
you know i know a lot of people like to
say oh i don't i don't care to talk
about the trump family and they're not
in office right now but it's assumed
within the fall trump is going to
announce he's running maybe he just
unveiled the the newly renovated
modernized 757 yeah he's going to be
running all the people we've had on the
show who who worked with trump have said
he's going to be running
is there any fair criticism of his
family are we overlooking anything with
with with trump jr now i'll be i'll be
right off the bat i'm pretty sure none
of them are doing crack or transporting
process or anything close to that if
there's anything close to that it would
be
every major story every major headline
but my question is more so the more
important things like business dealings
yes like so uh the only thing that i saw
that really like caught my eye was that
ivanka trump supposedly used sweatshop
labor which i know beyonce does as well
so it's not really a fair
shot well so she's basically like
beyonce then yeah that's a good thing
yeah that's great yeah but it's hard not
to be involved with it
that's glamorous like if you use
teespring to sell your t-shirts they're
probably sourcing them from chinese
sweatshops right hey we used these for
you yeah i know yeah hey welcome to
welcome to the fascist reality no i
think it's
sorry that you're perfect little fingers
can make a great shirt
yeah look i got these these these
hands with calluses from playing the
guitar i couldn't i don't know i don't
know where
we need to be
i can't make nikes this young boy can
he's very talented
that's the argument is that they're
better off getting 25 cents per day than
not having jobs at all i mean which is
like the craziest that's the worst i
mean that's what you told me when you
hired me it's like
that's so funny because it's like no no
they're chilling
it's like no they're children they're
better off not having jobs at all yeah
they're better off playing yeah i think
kids need jobs i think kids need jobs i
think i like like allowance jobs
no but i mean like family business jobs
yeah you know like take out the trash
that's what i do with my son yeah yeah
but like um
it used to be great when kids would work
with dad but not to the extent where
they're like in a factory sewing
industrial level or
yeah they're not like you would hold the
flashlight for your dad not actually
build a car exactly exactly yeah but you
know um being an assistant an apprentice
uh uh
doing like you know my family at a cafe
so taking out the trash and ringing
people up and stuff that's the kind of
job kids needs it looks like teespring
may actually not use slave labor uh but
they they ship from the eu if you're
ordering internationally and then from
kentucky if you're ordering domestically
shout out to teespring
well i got a problem with those filthy
europeans so i actually i'm gonna go
back to the chinese slave way it's
actually not sure it's young european
pickpockets
[Laughter]
i actually i had a guy try robbing me
when i was in barcelona seriously
yeah he was acting drunk barcelona and
he was like putting his arm around me
and i was pushing him off and he was
like oh come on come on and then he
grabbed my phone it was on a clip on my
bag because i was working he grabbed it
and pulled and then i swapped him away
he didn't get it and then he went
pointed at me and then sobered up like
that just walked off wow because he knew
he lost it he knew like he has one
chance to pretend like he wasn't causing
problems yes
but i like that he just ended it by
being like well played and just dipped
off into the night
i mean he just could my phone was on a
clip and he grabbed it and pulled and it
was stuck to my back yeah i was like get
pull harder i don't know
well as i'm reading more about teespring
i don't know people are saying they
don't know teespring doesn't disclose
where they actually produce their stuff
the next one is just puppy fur being
made into shirts
i'll be looking into this as the days
they throw puppies into a grinder yeah
yeah
yes i gotta admit i was way off
uh don't eat items
now you're ragging on items no i'm only
doing that because they did stuff too
yeah
they had like uh like horses yeah i
don't know what that it was now it was
with puppies like they were recycling
puppies yeah yeah it was bad it wasn't
they did bad things i don't buy i don't
buy their brand baby they were serving
dog meat secretly yeah i think yeah or
like testing the meats in ways that were
just horrible like i remember seeing a
lot of like yeah beagles like stacked on
top of each other which could have just
been fouchy's house
but there weren't a lot of flies
i want to go back and mention you know
when we talk about like the trump family
you know i mentioned it because they're
probably gonna be running but you look
at how they go after like baron remember
remember when they act that was attacked
him for his name yeah things like that
he's like a teenager and for being
special needs oh yeah
isn't he i don't know i think he's a
little hustler he's slightly autistic
yeah like a math genius or something
yeah that was always like yeah that's
what a horrible
number one that would have been really
funny if you were trying to defend him
and you're like when they went after him
for being special needs he's not special
needs oh well i thought he was oh i feel
for baron the whole time i kind of felt
like that was happening right now
remember when
they they ran this big story claiming
that don jr had privy access to
wikileaks oh really and then it turned
yeah and then trying to be fake they
were like
the email that he sent about wikileaks
came like well after what he looks at
already published a bunch of stuff and
they're trying to make it seem like they
were colluding with russia i mean i'll
do my
patented tim cast old liberal confession
where i never read stories on the trump
kids but just from the headlines i would
see or the way people would talk about
them i totally just assumed they were
just these like privileged drug addicts
i kind of assumed they were the same as
like similar to like hunter biden types
and i don't yeah i didn't know anything
i don't know meanwhile don junior's out
there handing cans of soup to the home i
certainly didn't see that story right
yeah i don't know if he's actually doing
that either but you know who's like
hunter biden though is nancy pelosi's
son paul pelosi jr he has a wild history
too he's not as bad a drug drug addict
but he's every bit as corrupt i think he
probably needs his patsy too his dad
drove drunk yep was it is his father
that was that was recently right yeah
well yeah his wife wanted to have sex
and
just drove into a jeep
okay all right you you you this is your
fault oh did we get pulled off no no no
no no no
you opened the door
in the court of timkas now i got to
mention that photo of nancy pelosi that
went viral oh no why would you do that
oh i photoshopped it with my face on it
walking with hillary and uh
i didn't know it was heard first my
friend ellie did one of my friends
texted it to me and goes uh jamie's
about to become a neolib and i like open
and i was like oh no
okay for those that don't know it it was
nancy pelosi going to the beach
and
good for her bazongas would be the
cartoon word i would use
massive i was stunned i mean what was it
who tweeted like i'm ashamed of how i
feel right yeah yeah jesse yeah
yeah yeah i just did it
i was like i'm not i don't know
i feel like all the pills she takes go
right to her breasts
i'm still depressed but these are huge
here we go this one's good we got to
play this clip this is so disclosed.tv
tweeted new new york city emergency
management shared a video today
outlining the important steps for new
yorkers to follow if a nuclear attack
occurs
and my first question is why
and uh they've created a modern eyes let
me let me play this video for you
so there's been a nuclear attack don't
ask me how or why just know that the big
one has hit okay so
what do we do
there are three important steps that i
want you to remember
step one
get inside fast you your friends your
family get inside and no staying in the
car is not an option you need to get
into a building and move away from the
windows
step two
stay inside
shut all doors and windows until the
middle of the step three
radio action
follow media for more information
don't forget to sign up for notify nyc
for official alerts and updates
and don't go outside until officials say
it's safe
all right
you've got this
like i i couldn't help but notice that
it's another emergency preparedness
thing about not leaving your home you
know we had like cove don't go outside
yeah now it's like nuclear text don't go
outside well first of all
tim and i were watching this before we
went on air no new york city apartment
looks like that right when she was like
get into your basement i was like what
are you a billionaire a basement my
bedroom was my bathroom she means your
basement apartment that costs you 800
bucks
and it's like a single cement cube
yeah also get inside are you sure
in a lot of those rickety old buildings
oh right that's right after an attack
that's not really good well i mean well
but they said
they go get inside and stay away from
windows
get inside and make sure you get right
to the windows that was the second step
it's like which one you want me to do
should i get to the windows yeah the
first one was get in and get away from
the windows and step number two shut
doors
shut the doors and windows shut them
yeah so what do you want me to do wow
i can't shut them i'm too far away which
one do i say i thought you wanted to get
away from the windows and now you're
telling me to go at them i'm already
confused and this is just the first
instruction the i also her jovial tone
was a little um
a jarring when she's like so there's
been an attack and just kind of like
sexily walked onto the screen and when
she tried to make the joke like no silly
a car isn't inside you're about to burn
to death it was very bad and by inside
we mean you'll be under a ton of bricks
on fire
and the survivors will be having
three-headed dead babies for the next
ten years when you get up to heaven what
is happening my first question for the
panel is
what are you talking about why are they
putting out a how to survive a nuclear
strike video uh tim did you not listen
to the beginning when she said don't ask
why yeah it doesn't matter how it
doesn't matter how or whatever
yes it does new york lady it definitely
matters i think russia obviously
i think
it feels cold warish doesn't it
can i can i just i pulled up the nuke
map i love this website i guess this is
where hot water you pick a city and then
you can pick the weapon so i've i've
chosen the largest icbm which is the
titan ii warhead
it's a nine megaton bomb there is
literally nowhere in new york you will
survive yeah new york city that is new
york city right nice um well look
uh i guess
where's queen ends where does where does
queens end
queen ends
i'm pretty sure flushing
flushing
and jamaica but good name is that still
new york city flushing is where you say
something okay so you are you are in the
thermal radiation radius and will suffer
third degree burns i suppose you would
want to be inside but i'd imagine
i don't know where you're in new york
and you'll see an icbm coming and be
like well i better go inside better look
at the basement
if you are in
like so look at this like new jersey
hoboken by even newark you're in the
blast damage area
let me be fair newark has been in the
blast lightning blast damage
yeah they do already look like this has
happened
oh that's the yeah thermal okay so the
fireball radius takes out the financial
district up to um
around midtown union square and flatiron
gets wiped out in a fireball then
everything around
around here
up to the bronx
all of the jersey coast
and up to queens and flushing brooklyn's
gone except for like coney island i'm
excited for brooklyn to be like how do
we gentrify rubble
yeah but that's that's the moderate
blast damage coffee shop
most residential buildings collapse
injuries are universal fatalities are
widespread most buildings collapse but
they're telling people to get in their
buildings i mean where else is
it would have been funny
if in this video she says
if you're in the areas of the bronx
flushing jamaica coney island get into
your building everyone else
see you later yeah yeah yeah if you're
seeing earlier if you're rich
get into the pod we gave you right here
let me tell you this is the titan ii
this is the highest yield
intercontinental ballistic missile the
u.s has ever deployed okay if we go for
like the larger bombs so like iv mike is
10 megatons what if we hit it with for
example sorry not to interrupt like the
one you just said i don't i think it's
only been tested
the only news i think we ever used was
fat boy and was it a little boy and fat
man okay
yeah uh little boy in fat man yeah that
was 15 and 20 kiloton wow so let's let's
say somebody dropped a fat man on on
manhattan i mean yeah okay maybe then
you're like get inside because that
would only take out the financial
district but we're talking about modern
icbms so we have the bigger bombs we
have sar bama that's the largest ussr
bomb tested it's 50 megatons but that's
a gravity bomb bomb meaning a bomber
came in and dropped it they would never
get into u.s airspace it's not going to
happen right but let's say
the uh the titan ii warhead is nowhere
near the current level of technology
that we've actually developed or russia
has and they've actually got a 50
megaton icbm okay you're not going
anywhere sorry you're talking
new york city doesn't exist anymore
stamford is getting hit what else do you
got like
all gone new brunswick is gone all of
like the north northeast jersey coast is
just wiped out sorry if the bomb's
bigger than nine megatons hey what do
you um
what's your thought on
why
do you think they do you think that new
york was like hey this is a legitimate
threat we need to warn people with weird
advice and a goofy psa or do you think
it is some sort of distraction for
something like i mean there was a
meeting about this there was a
production they made it what do you
think they were thinking and why they
made it you know what honestly
i have no idea but i am wondering if
they're just sitting there you know and
dude's like spinning his pen he's like
we got 30k in the budget and we got to
use it this month it's like yeah we
could do a nuke psa yeah yeah that
sounds fun like oh i've been sleeping
with this actress who's been dying for
work like we'll get her in she's very
very charming yeah we did the fentanyl
testing one all right yeah
i mean really united air and box cutters
that's been done uh what else do we got
like what do you get like comments are
turned off on the video unfortunately
crazy well yeah cause there's probably a
lot of questions right
seventy seconds like she says we don't
know why yeah it doesn't matter also but
yeah like i wanna point out jamie
mentioned in the video she's in like a
ritzy loft i mean look at that look at
that couch this is what i'm saying yeah
she's worth millions and millions yeah
look at that size spaciously behind her
yeah
unless my apartment's so big i don't
have room for all my stuff i would say
it could be like 10 new york hipsters
living in one yeah i was gonna say where
are her 15 roommates but look at her
flooring it could be black friends the
remake this this this video was made for
rich new yorkers oh wow
yeah you know who i'm talking to
everyone wink yeah when the newt comes
get inside right you know what i mean
get near the windows that have the
special drapes
i've been listening um lex friedman has
been talking i i don't know i have a lot
of respect for lex friedman you know if
you guys listen to him he's yeah he's
artificial intelligence scientist also
does jiu-jitsu uh in austin
he's actually over there in ukraine
right now he's jujitsu he's a black belt
what i know it surprised me too wow i
don't i'm nothing i'm not saying he's
better or worse than any of us but he's
been concerned about nuclear i mean when
i start hearing other people talk about
nuclear war like i don't really think
it's on the table but i mean i guess
everything's on the table
yeah but what i'm hearing about is these
hypersonic weapons that it's like forget
icbms they take a while to get here
these things are these faster than sound
weaponry no no i think uh hypersonic are
faster i mean i'm sorry i'm sorry icbms
are faster i might have a hypersonic
icbm
uh hypersonic are uh
slower so icbms go into space
and they move really really really fast
the the issue i think with the
hypersonic i could be totally wrong but
i thought it was detection is that it's
uh um like more uh conventional combat
detection it's easier also we have merv
weaponry where like a nuclear weapon
explodes in the atmosphere and then
creates like 70 new nuclear bombs that
all fall it just seems like there's so
many that we know of there's 12 warheads
in one icbms multi multiple
independently targeting re-entry
yeah so these singular blast zones are
like
just quelling our fear you know we'd
have like 12 blast zones when we when
when i pull up the titan ii and put it
over new york or like look at that what
you don't realize is that we've
developed something called the multiple
independently targeting reentry vehicle
a mirv it goes up into the stratosphere
and then breaks and drops eight to
twelve warheads which could be deciding
pepper the whole eastern seaboard that's
actually what hunter biden calls ism i'm
sorry um no i uh uh he does pepper the
seaboard
he's the merv we need
i mean there's part of me
i'm not even being conspiratorial like
they're trying to cover it up but it's
at the best
wasteful where we have so many
real problems in this country with the
economy with mental health with drug
addiction with all the stuff we were
talking about right now that it's like
do we need to spend money on a psa for
like also maybe we're gonna get nuked
when we're probably not gonna get nuked
i wonder if they're watching the
wilkification of the military and
they're like oh we need to let people
know that this might actually happen
yeah
putin may have cancer which could lead
to like mental degradation and
desperation where he's just like i'm
going out on a bank yeah and like if
he's on like prednisone and it's messing
with his thoughts and he's like going to
become more likely to do something
stupid well because if he's terminal i
don't think he cares about anybody else
at that point right except his legacy
exactly right yeah very good point yeah
here's here i'll show you this crazy
this is crazy so um
if dc were to get hit with the surface
strike we're fine we're up we're up near
uh charlestown over here so we're
totally we're fairly far away new york
actually gets hit
so take a look at this map where new
york gets hit with the radioactive
fallout from washington from washington
look at that it stretches all the way up
and we're talking
we're talking uh
this is this is
500 uh rem
34.6 so that's very much right in the
center sorry i don't think it gives us
okay here we go here we go
the fallout that would hit new york is
one rats per hour oh no i'm sorry no new
york it's whoa
new york gets hit heavy
10 rads per hour wow that's that's nuts
the fallout just
what's up philadelphia's
yo baltimore's gone bel air you're all
in the max
the max radius for fallout that's
absolutely brutal delaware's getting
some sprinkles
yup jersey's jersey i mean this is a rat
as a radiation absorbed dose
so it's a unit of measure for radiation
yeah about how much that you can take
and everybody who plays fallout no rads
are bad yes and this is just from the
air sweeping it or is this
instantaneously it's the it's the air
current moving carrying the radio to
fall out so we're still safe because the
uh jet stream carries in the other
direction but yo
one strike on you you have to know like
if it's russia or whoever or china they
know this if we can pull it up on some
silly little website yeah yeah if you
just taught it to me they know this
right right exactly
you just taught two comedians
okay on a podcast yeah they probably got
it
the craziest thing about it
the radiation is intentional they could
make the bombs have limited or no
radiation or i don't about no but like
like there are there are nuclear bombs
that have no radioactive fallout after
the fact hey no big deal tim and feel
free to say no but can dave and i stay
here in the basement
forever because i'm very frightened
well
i mean
i gotta no one's gonna nuke texas i got
actually nobody's gonna nuke detroit
oh that's true i got a house there and
there yeah it looks also you know
it's already been hit right exactly i
was gonna say they're gonna look at them
and be like no we already got yeah like
we did somebody did this
why would someone do this
no one like no one's gonna nuke the uh
dayton funny bone with both me and dave
will be performing august august august
everyone they're uh china and or
russia's they're looking at a map of
cities and they're like which ones if we
hit like putin walks in and he's like
which cities and then they're like
pointing and all the smoke rising is
like what about detroit and they're like
that wasn't us actually no no really
really well somebody did a very good job
yeah
yeah we did they did yesterday they did
that
we have to stop them no it's the
citizens really they're good
yeah they just see all the cities that
we've destroyed that the way to get us
back they're like i guess we help them
rebuild
for a shake nashville hot dog joint
giving out free milkshakes with proof of
vasectomy
so uh congratulations
i saw i saw this tweet where this dude
was like your children will be going to
school with immigrants and weirdo
conservatives right because liberals are
all removing themselves from the gene
pool here's here i'll just break it down
very simply for all y'all
more likely to have an abortion
substantially
substantially less likely to have kids
substantially more likely to get
hysterectomies
vasectomies um together
whatever it's called the tubes tide yeah
ma'am we're we're really the party of
fun over there um more likely to
sterilize their own children yeah yeah
so
i just gotta say i the the liberal left
is very unlikely to exist as an ideology
or tribal group in 40 years but i agree
i don't know what everybody's getting so
worked up about when they're chanting
about like being pro-choice and it's
like they're really just getting rid of
it
that's here's the crazy thing not even
being a
dick i'm just serious conservatives
the reason why abortion was
it was a guarantee
that abortion that roe v wade would have
been overturned
anybody in the 90s could have just
looked at a simple arithmetic and been
like in 20 years abortion will be made
illegal why conservatives have kids
conservatives don't want abortion
liberals abort their kids they want
abortion to abort their kids the math is
simple over a long enough period of time
the voting bloc becomes more
conservative and then votes away
abortion
bringing back more liberals i never
thought that would be the main problem
with democrats is that we aborted all of
our voters well that's why they want to
bring in uh more immigrants the funny
thing is they say that they're like we
want to bring in more immigrants we want
to strengthen our voting block and then
when tucker carlson says it they're like
yeah he's a racist uh-huh well of course
that's the magic word yeah of course
well even rbg was kind of against roe vs
wade i mean my opinion on it is you know
different than obviously what my show
does it's sort of do you know do what
you do
i i don't care but
i just don't think that the the way
they're going about it right now makes
any sense at all well and when you
you know i talk about tribalism and
online fighting how so much of it is
fake and when you actually talk to
people who disagree with you in real
life you can figure out that a lot of
you actually do want the same thing you
know because you go on twitter and it's
like well one party wants to kill women
and one party wants to kill babies and i
think there are still a lot of people
out there who
they're not pro-choice because they're
pro-abortion but they're pro-choice in
like really terrible circumstances um
and i think when the left started going
started changing it i think libby
edmonds tweeted this where she she had a
tweet where it's like when the left
stopped saying
safe rare and legal and started almost
bragging and boasting about abortions
and positions and pushing that
look at all my abortions it gets a
little gross right and then it's like
all right well now people are going to
go even harder to overturn it um whereas
maybe it was safer when it was i got i
want to give you a little bit a little
bit of pushback and i'm going to pull up
our good friend she went ahead oh yes
with the ground news blind spotter i'm
pulling this up quite literally because
it's actually a bit that shu did she was
doing an ad for ground news and she said
you can use their their blind spotter to
show where if where you consume your
news
shoe one head on twitter 86 of the news
that she interacts with leans left 86
86 does that mean things she she
comments on comments on shares and it's
like washington post a link charlotte
observer we'll go back and we'll do this
is what she did ben shapiro
and ben shapiro is 40 right 39 left wow
so this is the issue interesting you go
to a conservative who's who's pro-life
and they will explain to you the policy
what they think of roe v wade and why
you go to a liberal and they'll say the
right are evil and they hate women
that's exactly that's what i used to say
i mean that was the conversation i had
with sheamus the first time i came on
the show i was legit that's why i was
asking you and seamus yeah where i was
like hey can you tell me because i
literally just heard if you say you're
pro-life at all you just hate women
right you want women to give birth to
rape babies and like that's your life
but so and that it's all about jesus it
makes sense that these that they're more
likely to
remove themselves effectively from the
gene pool and i'm not saying it to be
crass or anything but it's lit it's
literally true i don't listen to that
you want to play oh yeah i want to see
jamie's i want to see jamie oh yeah this
is good jamie's changed a lot what's
your what's your twitter
it's my name
this is just a way to plug my twitter by
the way oh my twitter it's at jamie
kilstein no he's biased don't follow him
oh i'm sure
am i still super left you're super loud
what's your what's your twitter dave at
landau dave yeah
could i have landed can i just take this
moment to say that i think that needing
to defend your eyes
can any can everybody who calls me now a
right-wing grifter can i just send them
over to this yeah sure yeah yeah this
political blog spot what's called blind
spotters i don't know if that would help
the case it's a lot of sense of this i
don't oh no they're saying i'm a
right-winger oh my gosh
it's because you interact with tim
caster the most maybe it's the only one
i've seen where it's the majority of it
is center but it's because you tim cast
i mean that's kind of gem cast that's
cool though
sour patch lids oh no no yeah that's a
batch of honey yeah
hold on i just always feel like you
should actually listen to both sides but
the one side is becoming really just way
too you know why this is also i no
longer try oh because you're already
you're trolling them no yeah that too
but also because i follow a bunch of
journalists that's pretty much why i'm
on twitter yeah exactly i think it was
actually the same tim that's good so
yeah you look at me you look at ben
shapiro elon musk you look at michael
malus you look at even jack posobik has
got more left on his his uh than
leftists but it's obvious
it's it's this is the issue that's
always been with the left i'm still
disturbed that mine looked like gnome
chomsky was on twitter that was very
upsetting
yeah i think but that this is why blind
spotter is great you know shout out to
ground news you know we're not doing a
spot spot for him but this is the issue
when it comes to uh pro-life when this
is the issue when it comes to taxes yep
they literally have no idea what they're
talking about well and by the way that
is kind of actually proof to what i was
saying where
you know i was talking to dave about
this beforehand and you know i've gotten
a couple i mean your fans have been
awesome but i've had a couple of my old
school fans be like i'm leaving or i'm
not going to support the patreon just
because i'm on the show they haven't
listened to me on the show they haven't
listened to what i said but because i'm
on the show i'm giving credit to tim
which therefore somehow i'm like a trump
supporter it's been very weird messages
and
that is how a lot of them
think where it's the second you
you know
talk to someone on the right you're
automatically a grifter you're
automatically supporting everything
they've ever said and
what i'm
really enjoying about talking to more
conservatives or people in the middle or
libertarians or liberals who are
disenfranchised with the left is i'm
just educating myself i feel like for
the first time ever because like you saw
my chart where i wasn't being sarcastic
when i was like i could tell me pro-life
stuff because i don't know like i just
learned about guns this year only
because i moved to texas
but it was just i just had my talk
you're given your talking points these
are the talking points you just shout
whether it's you're racist whether it's
you want kids to die if you're pro-gun
you want women to die if you're pro-life
blah blah blah and then you just do
those and you just try to shout as loud
as you can and then you get retweets and
then you go to bed sad and depressed and
that's it sounds great it was a sweet
life yeah i just want to say real quick
before we move on i think the case can
be made that encouraging diversity of
viewpoints like the right wing does much
more than the left does and the right
has to defend their views much more than
the left does it's much more of an echo
chamber on twitter for the left wing but
i think that encouraging that diversity
of thought is going to mean the literal
difference between life or death as far
as demographics go we're going to keep
right-wingers alive what i think this
proves is that if you are a balanced
individual you are right wing and if you
are in a cult
i don't know i i fall center like i had
62 percent but i don't think you need to
pick a side that's because you actually
don't do a lot of news it's like
timcast.com
i don't click on a lot of political mags
that's for sure look my point is
all of these right-wing personalities
ben shapiro
his news is from a balanced perspective
and they're like he's far right michael
malus he's new right and he's he's more
he he consumes more left that news than
i do
oh absolutely so if you are someone who
gets your news from from a mixed batch
and you've formed your opinions off of
real information you are considered
right wing that's insane the left are
people who are in echo chamber who have
no idea what's happening in the world
and the right is everyone else
oh absolutely well i assure you too like
we looked at crowders it's probably
because when we look at our show all day
we all watch cnn we all watch every bit
of left-wing media because we have to
look at our side against that so that's
the only thing we consume all day is to
see what their side is we don't watch
any other news source than that so i'm
sure by the time he jumps on twitter
it's like all right well what's this
this and this you know to kind of see
where those certain talking points are
for me
like when i got into you is because
somebody who
had a viewpoint i had where i always
felt that i was i was left i was always
raised in that kind of a
group friends whatever i just thought
the world was a certain way
i i don't even know if i'd say right or
whatever this is now i just know that
it's completely gone to a place where i
have been pushed over to this side in
the business that i'm in being a
comedian wanting what i want like we
were talking about punk music like
johnny rotten said he never thought he'd
live to see the day that you know the
rights were the ones giving the middle
finger to the establishment where trey
parker said that the right is the new
new punk rock it's just different now
it's shifted because it's gone so far
the other way that that is anything that
you say is just completely unforgivable
and 95 of the internet outrage is for
currency not because they actually feel
anything i really but so i view that as
the exception on the right and the rule
on the left yes the right has a whole
bunch of people who are genuinely saying
like here are my thoughts
and then the left has the majority of
their prominent figures are what do i
have to say to rail people that's right
david the right has those people but
yeah they do it's it's it's the
exception not the rule on the left has
some good people who make points they
believe in but they're not the most
prominent
um dave as a comic was there i don't
really know what was there like a
transition or like a a creep moment for
you because we were talking about you
were opening for chappelle when
chappelle was doing stuff against george
bush and all this stuff when did
did you just get the gig at crowders as
a gig and then it started happening or
was there like a creep well i was at
anthony kumia's show who i always loved
from opiates that's right and i was
there for years and i was already then
and i used to sub mike malice's show all
the time because he would go
on the road to different shows and
everything and i'd just like doing his
show because like i just turned it into
just kind of like a weekend update
you know dick jokes that mike would
appreciate and then make it as dark as
humanly possible
and uh i always like doing that but
because i joined that network all of a
sudden i had people angry at me because
of something that anthony didn't
actually say but was said that it was
said right a guy who was patrice
o'neill's best friend and a show
everybody wanted to be on who all of a
sudden was an outcast that's that's what
i grew up on i grew up on all of the you
know yeah
i was opening for patrice who i went to
found out about if it wasn't opinion
anthony and all those guys and yeah and
anthony is one of my heroes so now i'm
sitting next to one of my heroes and you
see this this bitterness come out where
all of a sudden it's like well that
guy's racist that guy's this that guy's
dead i can't believe mike mouse is all
right it's like no you're just
you don't understand anything and you
just want to be enraged either by the
fact that i'm doing something that you
want to do or because somebody else has
told you something that you want to
believe and what but you weed out who
your real friends are very very you're
telling me for sure and i've learned
that through even being on crowder
crowder and i clicked his dad grew up in
detroit kind of by uh where i did and we
we connected that's how i met stephen
and as a result of that yeah i've caught
a lot of crap for it but at the same
time i've gotten a lot of great fans
from it and met a lot of good people and
that's just part of this i mean that's
just part of this game with jamie it was
actually a really interesting
transformation i remember we first met
he was protesting one of our events and
he threw a brick at me right yeah and
then we brought him inside and he was
like i will i will always be your rival
and enemy and then i hand him a check
and he looked at the number and said i'm
pro-life one yeah yeah
yeah i i actually wrote mega on the
brick he got on the phone he was told
his girlfriend to keep the baby
that was actually a joke we did on cass
castle aware
jamie's like i'm not going to these
right-wing events and then was it carter
yeah he's like oh that's a bummer
they're taking a private plane i'm like
you know what i got to bring everyone
together yeah
i was throwing a milkshake at a gay
asian reporter right
did you get um did comedy clubs ever
try to stop you or because you had a
following from this new audience they
didn't care and it was just more people
on twitter um at first for a second they
did and then uh
like somewhere like well i don't then
tickets were being sold and they were
like i don't mind no big deal yeah
exactly everything's
i am loud with crowder as well yeah yeah
it's it's all business and people have
and i remember my buddy freddy is a
black dude who runs uh hartford
connecticut not to say race but it is
important to the story there were proud
boys standing in line and i was like oh
i don't know if that's a good look and
he goes why they're not allowed to laugh
and i was like why do i say anything
yeah it's just because it's all a
business when you break it into the
actual reality of a situation so what uh
what i'm really interested in doing is
we've got we've got tim cascade boards
that we just we just designed we've got
uh step on snack and find out it's like
just like the t-shirt yeah and then we
have some some stock just like it says
like tim cast it's like i've sent them
to skate shops because i mentioned this
before if you have skate shop and you
want some free boards we're going to
send you free boards and you can sell
them for whatever you want
skate shops mind you
and i want to put on contests and so
i've had a conversation with some people
about contests and like oh man you know
people might be worried about like the
politics and i'll be like we'll do a
massive cash prize like we we obviously
can't rival some of the biggest cash
prizes but we'll get a couple grand up
there so it's like
it'll it will it will be a contest
people like oh you know like it's a
couple grand for a day's work you know
or more
and uh i was told yeah but some people
might just be like um it's not worth it
because you're gonna make maybe 40 grand
in contests this year and you do that
one for five grand dollars like 10 grand
first place
now all these people who might
pretend to have political convictions
might be like
oh and by the way can i order like my
yearly income in one day
come on down to the skate count we're
not gonna do anything crazy we're not
gonna be political we're gonna have a
regular old skate contest but we're
gonna do a good cash prize big event
bring out the families get everybody
invited and we'll see who really is
gonna put their money where their mouth
is exactly well and also
the frustrating thing for
what i try to tell people the ones who
are bailing on me for being on the show
is
i've already
had i've been on the show what this is
my fourth time in a couple weeks i've
already had fans come to my show um who
discovered me on here who didn't know
about me or discovered me on here and
what the left doesn't understand is now
i have a room full of liberals and
conservatives and some stuff i say makes
fun of liberals and some stuff i say
makes fun of conservatives and a lot of
stuff i say makes fun of me and we're
all laughing together that is what you
should want you should want
conservatives to hear my view you should
want um liberals to hear my view when we
do just stay in this echo chamber just
to feel good about ourselves you're
actually not convincing anyone that's
why there's so much infighting on the
left and you because they have they have
no one else to argue with because they
don't even talk to conservatives or
moderate so then they just like eat
their own
resistance it's a natural part of
existence we need resistance to survive
if a tree doesn't have wind resistance
it falls over and dies yep it makes it
stronger we need that
yeah and part of comedy should be it
should feel a little icky at times like
you want to feel a little evil and fun
like if if everything you say is
supposed to be offensive
is never offensive why is it why go to
comedy right it's supposed to feel a
little bit too much yeah that's what's
why why would you go to something that
triggers you right like why
here's the deal like
here's the deal fat look
fat with these comedy things you've got
these millennials who
are
fluffy pink and un uh and uncalloused
right squishy yeah squishy and frail
they their parents took care of all the
problems for them they grew up in the
epitome of luxury so they've never
actually been struck for any reason not
at all no one should be but it kind of
happens it should be yeah well so i know
what you mean no i i've tweeted that
everyone should work retail get punched
in the face and one more thing i don't
know sometimes that can all happen in a
day working week
yes
here's my point these people are soft
yes so when you say a mean word to them
it's the most pain they've ever felt so
to them it's like you have caused me the
most pain i've ever experienced
growing up in the city you get into
fights i don't care if someone says
naughty words to me right but what
happens then as they go to a comedy show
the most
comedy they've heard is probably like
teen titans go or you know fairly
oddparents or powerpuff girls yes so
they're watching these goofy little
cartoons where the joke is that someone
spilled milk and then cried and it's
like you're crying over spilled milk oh
it's so funny then you go to a comedian
and he says he calls you an ins he calls
you a slur and you're like
and it's like he punched you in the gut
it's the worst pain you've ever
experienced they lose their minds well i
finally started reading uh cod the
coddling of the american mind and you
know some of these college protests when
they were protesting milo or protesting
ben shapiro they were literally saying
we have to use violence because their
words are violence against me and it's
like they're not violence though yeah
that concerns me you could break
someone's eardrums with a loud enough
noise in that instance
volume amplification can be construed as
violence but the the definitions of the
words are not violence no of course
maryland or not marilyn manson uh what's
his name charles manson sorry merrill
um
i wouldn't apologize to maryland he's
got a whole bunch oh yeah he's going
through some something right now
you can incite violence with words but
the words are not violence violence
happens as a result of the incitement of
the usage of the peaceful form of
communication yes
absolutely
comedy is just fun when it's edgy man i
mean the stuff we grew up you're
supposed to have an edge that's the
point your edge may not even be dirty
though i mean that's the thing
steven wright has an edge it's not a
dirty edge but it's an edge yeah i mean
there's there's an edge to everything
yeah you can do really good wholesome
comedy absolutely but it's not i'm just
kidding oh no but talking about poop
like you got to be able to talk about
the dirty stuff too you have to i really
george carlin had like the hippie to be
weatherman yeah you know what i mean it
was it was non-offensive it poked at
nobody it was not edgy at all it was a
good bit it was just
an impersonation of a silly weatherman
and it was a trend you know it was him
tr uh sort of evolving from that two-man
group that he was in and getting into
this new hippie phase and oh yeah and
then all of a sudden he stopped telling
jokes and started just railing on the
federal government
and then getting arrested with lenny
bruce yeah
literally with him and uh literally tim
i'm glad you brought up carlin too
because it's been so interesting on
twitter in different
different times in the last couple years
seeing the right use carlin to hold up
their point or then seeing the left use
carlin to hold up their point and it's
like that's how you know he was good
that's how you know he was good he he
was just speaking his honest thoughts
and if the right can grab on to it
because it's something he said about
free speech cool if the left can grab on
to it because it's something he said
about environmentalism or abortion cool
he wasn't trying to pander to either
side he was just being him look at dave
chappelle they just put up that thing on
netflix where he gave a speech yeah at
his alma mater and uh i don't watch the
whole thing i watched
just a few minutes of it but that's a
little bit of what he says he's like you
just got to be the kind of person who's
strong and you like knows yourself you
can't let these people you know get mad
at you or whatever yeah and for a long
time he did like he lived leaving the
thing that he loved and had to deal with
that and then come back
and then deal with it ten times more
than you deal with it before yeah before
was because people almost loved him too
much and he couldn't stand going to the
grocery store being hounded being
attacked you know and now it's the
opposite you know what i don't
understand
is is that if you're if you if you would
do something you love yeah and then
people try to cancel you and say oh this
is a bad thing like comedy is the the
perfect example
i don't understand how someone could
stop you know what i mean like i enjoy
skateboarding yeah imagine a bunch of
people started protesting saying like
you're destroying the trees you're
promoting a destructive lifestyle i'd be
like okay well that sucks your piss but
i like doing it i'm gonna keep doing it
i did always wonder why you skateboard
while spraying aerosol cans in the air
just two of them
unloading lighting forest fires
[Laughter]
it's because i don't like winter all
right and i'm like i'm doing my part
speaking of forestry but i i just can't
i'm scared of snowman that's a great
point i can't imagine being a comedian
being like i love telling these jokes oh
i just thought of something that was
really screwed up that happened to me
that's really funny and then people are
like you're a racist like i better not
tell anybody ever ever again why if you
love doing it like tell your jokes you
know we're all gonna be dead one day i
mean that's the reality so just do it
yeah i mean that's i mean i realize
that's bleak no but i mean you might as
well but that's what you love funny
you're saying that but then like you
know in 10 years they discover
immortality and then like
they're going to be thinking they'll be
depicting your face with making you say
things that you never said is a form of
community community damnation i don't
know what it's for plus now that we all
know if there's a nuke you just have to
go inside and we'll be fine i think
we're fine that's true yeah we're gonna
live forever have you ever have you
heard these ai songs
no they've taken songs and then they've
asked ai or machine learning algorithms
to make the song longer oh they've been
making music with no soul for years
this is crazy they'll be like you're
talking about boy bands
they take a song and they say add two
more verses
and then the ai will create
and it's like you can hear the person
singing
i was listening it's not horrible it's
just weird imagine they do this for
comedians
they take all the comedy you've ever
done
load it up into a machine learning
algorithm or ai and then say make jokes
better yet you know
facebook is is apparently they're going
to make dead they're going to make like
ai ghosts
imagine they take your facebook profile
along with your comedy and then create
a u facsimile and then have it right
comedy it's gonna i was thinking it was
uh duncan
on rogan they were talking about it
might have been duncan talking about
this ai image generator now where you
can be like show me joe rogan
flying on a pegasus in the style of da
vinci are you saying that i can confirm
it was duncan it will yeah and it will
write it it will draw it up and they're
saying you know in the future it's going
to be porn it's going to be you're going
to be like show me joe rogan getting
railed by three guys and it's like oh
yeah it's going to show you that in
animated it's going to be create
animations of what you say so it'll be
like tell me dave orlando talking
telling jokes about captains i can't do
that right now tim poole's accent i can
do that right now and that's what i'm
talking about dude it is coming doll e
is so so
there's the doll e mini that everyone
means it's a good word
that's what it's called i'm good buttons
uh everyone memed it because you'd go in
and someone wrote like uh
brian stelter as a potato and then it
creates weird images that him kind of
it's just him uh but there's a thing him
with the actual doll e system is private
but it creates detailed really so the
the the uh the example they give is like
draw me a cowboy a
a an astronaut riding a horse in the
desert in colored pencil and then it
generates that image next will be
animation then it's going to be even
video games you'll be like play me a
game like slay the spire with the art
form of fallout 4 in the game i'll be
created in front of you 10 years oh yeah
we could already do there's already
websites that can make ai songs for you
you go in and you say i want a song in
this theme and this tempo with these
kind of instruments and then it will
generate and give you like 10 different
versions really yup bro after hearing
life yeah i'm like a week living in west
virginia and i'm about to buy an axe and
a shotgun and just move into the woods
like i'm done with all this stuff dude
like halfway there yeah
and a good mailing system
so uh
they've done these studies and found
that people's
self-reported happiness increases when
they get out of cities of course of
course can i just tell you every day
when i come up to the studio
there are wild
raspberries everywhere
there's just hundreds of them guys i
don't want to blow up
tim for you to realize that he's
actually a really great guy but every
time i meet him in the driveway he gets
so excited to give me fresh raspberries
and it's this it's the most wholesome
thing i've ever seen jimmy come here to
the brush like under the trees literally
what are you doing i'm like this way
this way yes
i swear that's very i swear to god that
is not far from what happened and the
last time it happened little bunnies
were actually going by as true and i was
like if only people knew that this is
real tim dude it just rolls up to you
like wonka
this is legit yes jamie's laughing
because he's a city fault yeah he
doesn't have to stay dude bro up on the
mountain i was so scared you're walking
down the street and there's bunnies the
bunnies don't run from you when you walk
past them no when you're driving watch
you of course they stand there yep and
then we saw one bunny today and his ears
went down his eyes got all big and he
looked at me and i walked over i started
pulling these berries it's like candy is
everywhere
and then and then the best part the best
best part up in the mountain is when
there's just chickens everywhere yeah
because people have chickens they just
let them go yeah and then like the
chickens like walk around like looking
at you and you you know i i i'm doing i
used to joke to friends so i spent covid
i i realized yesterday
that where i have lived you know when
people say uh oh you get more
conservative as you get older i'm like
that's not true and then i looked at
where i lived and it went park slope la
arizona texas west virginia oh it's true
it's it's 100
and i um
i will say over covid you know i was
still more liberal than i am now
um i would kind of joke around like oh i
kind of like being a liberal but in a
conservative state where i get freedom
and now you know i'm more i will call
myself a bleeding heart centrist but i
if i didn't live in arizona and texas it
was the first year i was ever single
i've dealt with depression really bad my
whole life
i had a blast because i could actually
go outside and people weren't looking at
me weird if i wasn't wearing a mask
outside and when i got to texas i could
do jiu jitsu again and everybody was
fine and we were still trying to take
care of each other and if someone got
but it was fine we were doing jiu jitsu
every day when new york and la were
still horribly locked down like i don't
think depression wise if i was still in
la like there's part of me that i don't
think i would have made it like being in
nature being in a more free state it was
the first time that i was like oh okay
yeah maybe the the east coast liberal
left coast liberal thing yeah there's
not a lot of only fans accounts with the
background is bunnies and red
oh yeah that's pretty ai to draw i look
out my window yeah style of blue ridge
mountains yeah how can you not be happy
i walk outside
yo the field
bees everywhere yeah like bumblebee i
had a dream about the non-stingy ones
the non-stingy ones and they're chilling
you could walk through the field and
they just float around everything
it's like birds and then the birds are
singing we've got wild black raspberry
we've got wild blackberry the
wineberries are dominant they're
considered they're illegal in new york
actually
even possession i think yeah possession
of wine they're called wine raspberries
that's why they were doing stop and
frisk they're illegal in new york and
connecticut that's how insane these
cities have become what they do the
reason they're illegal is because
they're considered invasive and they
dominate and take over and kill off
other raspberries blackberries i gotta
say though black wild black raspberry
tastes the best yeah and there there's a
lot less of them because they get
destroyed by the wineberry yeah we took
a bike ride up to sharpsburg which is uh
just a little bit north of harpers ferry
in on the maryland side got some wings
and some ice cream on the way there it's
just wild raspberry as far as the eye
can see
the interesting thing was i saw a plant
you can see they're very thorny and then
i noticed they'd all been picked there
are like hikers and people who travel
with backpacks who just walk the
appalachian trail and they eat the wild
berries you know man you get out of the
city life just becomes so much more
magical and fun it is yes it really is
it was
did you guys grow up in or out of a city
oh mulberries too
we grew up everywhere i grew up in uh i
was born in detroit we grew up in a
suburb called gross point woods on the
border of harper woods which is like 8
mile and 94 in detroit so i grew up in
like the
lower middle class middle class part of
uh like a wealthy city and then like the
poorest east side at the time the the
worst city in america which is the east
side of detroit so it was like we were
they were like right on the line so it
was a really interesting place to grow
up because i knew kids that had
everything and i knew kids that had
nothing and it was a really really kind
of a little yeah really cool
yeah i was in new jersey i was in
between princeton very wealthy and
trenton so yeah yeah there's almost uh
there's really a line called mac avenue
and at the time in uh in detroit that
was like their time magazine even did an
article on it for the
difference in uh income was so insane
because you're talking about like a
million dollars a year and then like
nothing
we had i was in like northeast ohio so
we had farm town like relatives and i
was it was so boring as a kid like oh
we're going out to the farm yuck where's
my where's my nintendo northeast ohio
near akron oh yeah for sure i did i did
the funny stop a lot but it's uh right
in cuyahoga falls hell yeah yeah yeah
yesterday oh yeah right on town yeah
and but it wasn't until my adult life
that i've learned this appreciation for
nature and maybe this is part of like as
you get older you appreciate
conservatism i i was obsessed with video
games and technology as a kid now like
man just watching the horizon we were
out on a boat a couple weeks ago and my
friend's son was like hey look at this
video of trans or show me trailers like
you know when i'm outside i kind of want
to enjoy the horizon yeah it's another
kind of
experience yeah every every post
in the in the bay had an osprey on it it
was so cool just chilling we got to do
that more yeah
i was out with my so we were out with my
son um even last weekend over the fourth
of july we had no internet and cell
phone service we realized and which was
frustrating for the first like couple
hours yeah and then for four days it was
the greatest days like i realized why am
i so happy yeah dude like i feel cheery
and like not angry and yeah this is nice
and i realized oh i haven't looked at my
phone obsessively at all like this is
this is why i feel okay yes every no
news but fishing with my son every time
i leave my phone at home there's five
minutes of oh no followed by just i'm
free it's just complete bliss i just
bought an emf frequency blocking uh
fanny pack for myself so i'm gonna put
my cell phone in there it's gonna block
the radiation hopefully i won't be
getting bombarded by it and oh my god
you might be able to have it with you
without having to feel the facts yeah
well you'll put your phone in it and
it'll stop receiving or sending signals
so you just like cut yourself yeah
get off the grid man it's nice okay
that's why when i was driving here i was
like this is
spectacular yeah well and not only do
you even go from like a city-ish at
least cities kind of you know into
you're like wow look at this is
beautiful
it's right up in my car
it is true like when you're driving up
there's a bunch of rabbits and deer yeah
several they mostly just do their thing
so uh i have an electric motorcycle that
i i
uh go to and from coming from the studio
the deer don't care no i mean they just
sit there and they stare at you when we
were letting out fireworks on the fourth
the deer were just watching yeah and i
was like they weren't scared at all
they're just chilling
i mean they were chanting build a wall
which was a little unsettling we got to
get a super chat
here the best thing was we have uh
cocktown now we have chicken city and we
have cocktown
because all the roosters we can't have
all the bruises in one place which is
unfortunate because they sing do you
hear them in succession they were
harming out yeah harmonizing out there
it's really funny
yeah so roosters can live together if
there's no girls around
so all the boys feel that bro yeah right
we brought all the boys to what we call
stan and they have their own little area
now it's got an electric fence around
it's got a cooper on it we showed up and
there was this this like i guess
teenager deer was like a dude and dude
deer and he was just like staring at the
roosters watching him we walked up and
he was just in the coop area like in our
yards run by all the fences and
everything and he was just like what's
this guy doing and he just looks at us
and he looks back at the roosters like
whoa he's just like really excited to be
a deer you know it was just cool i just
want to say one more thing the the
nature stuff
that's huge i mean i remember being in
la once and putting my phone down i was
just walking to jiu jitsu in pasadena
and looking up and seeing mountains and
realizing that i literally had not
noticed mountains on my walk to jiu
jitsu because i'm just always looking at
my phone and you will feel like you are
on drugs whichever your kid's listening
drugs are bad the other thing i want to
say though is back to what we're talking
about with the comedy clubs is when you
also get off your phone and get off
twitter you realize that we are not as
horrible as twitter would make you feel
and there are good people out there on
both sides last thought before super
chats there was a power outage in la i
think was in the early 90s and people
inundated the police with phone calls of
a mysterious thing in the sky it was the
milky way they had never seen it
because of light pollution it's a story
in l.a it's a story that i read about
l.a fact check it maybe it's not real
get it out here wow you can on some
night well i don't know about the milky
way itself i see a lot of star clusters
though out there then they made fire in
the sky yes all right we got to go to
super chats yeah i'm going to read this
one right away because we just got it
from mr misik who says tim my son was
just born and i wanted to use this chat
to tell my wife she's going to be a
great mother
nice job
all right if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and head over
to timcast.com
at 11 p.m we are going to be publishing
just about then a members only version
of this show the tim cast irl after
hours which is not for kids it is not
family friendly it is uncensored and i
can only imagine it'll probably be
fun
it'll be really funny
dave's been
writing taking notes and just holding it
numb but i think
well fun so
all right uh oh we got another super
chat about babies spencer jones says
shut to my wife nicole who just gave
birth to my healthy twin daughter and
son need some step on snack onesies for
them we have those right yes that would
be a real bummer if they were writing to
the same girl they didn't know
we have step on his neck onesies i
believe
congratulations
raymond gene
raymond jean-marcus sandler jr says ahoy
dave it was a blast having on irl
awesome ahoy to you
all right
hank the hokage hill that would be
hilarious says tim there is no way that
icloud story isn't being suppressed by
corporate media i googled yesterday and
found one story ron donald 2024
yeah isn't it um
whenever you try and search one of these
stories it says it seems like this
results are changing a whole lot i saw
that today i saw someone screenshot that
when they were looking up and stuff i
was looking it up and that's what it
said i'm like oh maybe it was you yeah
no i i didn't tell you about it i was
doing my research and it's same thing
happened
we have confirmation that our current
teespring does not offer onesies but you
can get children's t-shirts there we
don't have onesies i don't think we did
not their tee spring anyway
right off the kid making them yeah
bootless regent says dave thanks for
coming to lapeer i was too drunk to
thank you properly at the time oh yeah
my pleasure thanks for coming to the
show where's the loop here uh it's uh
uh in michigan kind of uh just a little
bit outside detroit and people were good
and hammered because i decided to just
do a local bar it was fun though
two-pack shows which is full of fun
people has it gotten better after co i
mean i would imagine the answer is yes
but how much better is it since the
restrictions have been lifted it's it's
nice there especially because they were
very very bad a lot of people lost
businesses and livelihoods because
whitmer the governor there is just
ruthless
so to uh to watch everything kind of
turn around is very nice
so it's it's way way better there now
stefan
bucksev says hey tim give eric july a
shout out his ripaverse launch was today
he's already over 790 thousand in sales
and still rolling
what is that yeah what is ripper keep
hearing about it
oh wow that's cool i think he was
wondering if you could sell 10 000
copies and people are like yeah hold my
beer yeah i got you that's super cool
that's awesome
paulo says tim when you're gonna upload
an edited skate video part would love to
see one
and it's never really my thing you know
i've always filmed some clips throughout
my life but never really to make
anything too crazy there's a bunch of
old videos of me on youtube from like
2004 and 2005 skateboarding but um i
don't know maybe you know what we're
we're we're planning a show
which is going to be skateboarding it's
going to be probably its own website at
freedman but the supply chain crunch is
making it impossible to build stuff
so
um i think i've got a call with this big
company for skatepark construction
because we want to do contests so the
way contest will work is we'll do a
contest with a bunch of ramps we build
then when the contest is over we either
leave the ramp there as a permanent
skate park for the city
it's like a gift or we pick them up
semi-dismantle them and load them back
and bring them to our place to use so i
think we might actually end up building
skate parks for local communities that's
awesome
you find an area with some good ground
and then you might spend like fifty
thousand dollars
build a small little park do a small
little contest and then the community
gets to keep the skatepark that's
awesome yeah it's it's difficult because
it can get really really expensive so
50k
would make a really great indoor park
but if you're doing outdoor materials it
gets more and more expensive you'll need
steel or something like that
all right i mean in 90s movies they just
skated through malls
yeah awesome there's an abandoned mall
out here or just smoked weed and beat
the crap out of people with skateboards
that's it gleaming the cube man
i don't know what gleaming the cube
means i think it's a movie it's a movie
and i don't know what the phrase means i
knew mr meeseeks
the cube it was a skateboarding movie oh
1989. christian slater yeah
i don't think this cleaning the cube was
an actual no what it's skateboarding
it's not pump up the volume uh what is
it though
oh man gleaming the cube itself
is that the name of the movie
yeah it's got uh christian slater
stephen bauer richard heard
star man i haven't seen that in years of
praise since 1989 right sci-fi yeah by
the name
my
oh okay well i still haven't had the hot
dogs because i just got back today
oh we still have a whole bunch right
very excited i have not checked i didn't
have any of them this time around yet
yeah but i got to do we'll do it
together yeah we'll have to see grilling
on the weekends it's like fourth of july
forever yeah that's alright until the
end of the month the best maga month
all right
what do we got here some super chats
john
einerson says miss the hawk dave will
you ever come to florida also tim did
you ever play mass effect one of the
best rpg trilogies in my opinion i
didn't
uh i might grow the hawk back one day i
don't know it depends a mustache and a
hawk might be too much but i might do it
i might
yeah yeah and i'll be in florida uh i'll
be in florida tampa improv and port
charlotte at vassani's later on this
year so check it out um they're on my
website davelando.com tampa improv also
a great room yes it is this is really
fun it's really fun i just like florida
yeah because it's weird
it's tampa is weird like i can't figure
out yeah there's like a sex club sorry
it's a kid's watching there's like oh
ladies at the nightclub there's a lady
there's a
[Laughter]
kyle miller says how much for a live
reaction of all the hunter leaks in the
after show oh boy i mean i'd do it i'd
take one for the team oh no
all i need is you to follow me on
twitter
special episode i do it we like mystery
science theater
yes let's do it yeah that's the other
thing too we've got a bunch of uh just
as an aside i'm busting out the papi if
we do we're we're planning a show that
will be
you guys remember crossfire yeah yeah i
want to do something like that but i
want to be so adversarial i want to be
like smarter and more chill yeah so
we're planning that probably as like a
sunday show as a tim guest exclusive on
the website and the idea would be i
would love to get like a trans athlete
to talk with like uh a prominent
sexologist or something yeah or a female
athlete who opposes that like the
obvious one that we were talking about
like what if we actually had that
conversation yeah so the goal is to try
and do that it's very difficult because
as always it's harder to get the left
personalities to come on shows i know
i doubt they would i don't know
i mean comics i think that's awesome
though i think you should do it yeah or
maybe i just have a comic well comics
should be surprised
because i mean there's like you and a
comedian there's a lot of comics well
you remember when uh it's actually a
good idea i mean i would do it i'd be
like you want to do a lap it'll just be
her winning
with a ball hanging out of a bathing
suit coughing up blood because i'm not
good at sports
yeah the idea would be
bring on anyone be it left or right and
then have a comedian just attack them
relentlessly yeah no matter what they're
doing or saying just from like a
lifeguard stand above it just like i
said you agreed with me you're like no
no
oh we can call the show gaslighting then
yeah you're just you have a whistle a
little bit of sunscreen on your nose
we have a whole bunch of super chats
just saying ahoy ahoy and ahoy and
ahoy
i love it
all right seriously jk says tim our
community is being attacked and our
savings are being stolen by wall street
hedge funds we need help stopping hedge
fund shorters from bankrupting 535
thousand community members of celsius
network see cell short squeeze on
twitter please i'm not i'm not familiar
with that you guys know anything about
that stuff the celsius network is like a
network oh i don't want to misrepresent
the network but a lot of what these
crypto companies are doing is their
people will give them their crypto and
then they'll use that as collateral to
take out a loan from somewhere else then
they'll give that money to some other
crypto network that uses that as
collateral so it's ponzi scheming again
it's the same fractional reserve crap
and they're getting their what they
deserve i think no offense i mean i
support the crypto community but if you
play that game you're going to get
destroyed that's what happened at the
great depression you see it now yeah
you're not really self-investing either
by yourself like through a like coinbase
or a certain exchange you're trusting
somebody else with your assets that's
unregulated all right that guy says
ian thank you for constantly reminding
everyone of the afghanistan surrender
it's easily lost among the multitude of
scandals fyi the bomber that killed 13
of my brothers was a bagram freed
prisoner fjb wow thank you so much thank
you for bringing it up it's nice to hear
someone else mention it thank you so
much eric kay says my red pill moment
was when colbert made fun of eric trump
who
who was kid who had done or said nothing
political
the fact that they will not touch hunter
biden other than to cover for him is
sick
yup i would say a good gnomon too is
when he had the dancing syringes on his
show the vaccine needles that was like
the moment where i realized late night
was dead and i never wanted to be on it
it's crazy isn't it it was really the
most disturbing thing i had ever seen on
late night i mean again when we came up
all you wanted was a letterman set yeah
a set on conan and i mean letterman was
just like gritty back in the day and
like he was a god yeah and conan was
weird i mean even like i wasn't a fan of
leno but apparently his hit leno's
standing he was very good at what he did
i'm like yeah yeah and now it's just
become so like
yeah i would say no i wouldn't i was
just advisor i'd like to political talk
shows yeah i'd like to give an honorable
mention
to brian linden
um for his troll attempt because it's
really good okay he says why are we
talking about nancy pelosi on the beach
when she's using an obscure
congressional rule to push through her
agenda without a vote just google nancy
pelosi rule 34 to find out more don't
google that don't do that nancy pelosi
is this the new lemon party oh my god
you know what rule 34 means no if it
exists there's porn of it
i'm not going to hit enter so do it ian
you type it
down
man i'm gonna do it
[Laughter]
all right
cva buck says nuke worker here after the
blast 15 minutes until fallout starts 24
hours is worst exposure time distance
shielding inside seal windows basements
mid floors best distance shielding from
roof ground where fallout settles wow
interesting
crazy man
so get in the building
yes
v gorilla says russian
uh what does it say sarnat or summet
says sarmat too makes the titan 2 look
like a firecracker plus it's second
generation hypersonic with mirvs there
is no defense against it one sarmat ii
can take out france
amazing man
thomas hen says look up the satan 2
nuclear mirv
yo just the name alone i was like yeah
that doesn't sound chill at all yeah
it's the second
awful name yes it is who's
poor merv
what is merv short for something
multi-mirven oh the name
many strange corks says i was a
maintainer in the usaf tightened to
icbms around wichita kansas most people
have zero idea of what a nuclear war
will do the closest movie i can
recommend is the day after 1982. it's
not bad enough though great show
appreciate it
i can't yeah i would imagine most people
do not know yeah they are dead yeah
i'll say i think the only time it's ever
actually been used in war is world war
ii and those were very small don't even
count as far you know as far as i can
tell 15 kilotons or whatever yeah
nothing
and they worked
raz grizz says icbm is faster but we
know all the launch spots and have
satellites whose entire mission is to
detect it hypersonics take longer but
extremely hard to detect and even harder
to intercept and they can turn on a dime
like turn 90 they can be headed towards
one city and then turn and go towards
another one
the future is seriously that's what i
was hearing last night
wow from one of these guys i don't
remember i listened to a lot of podcasts
last weekend
all right let's see sam em says i leave
for 10 minutes and now they've nuked new
york
they keep telling people you know or we
keep saying get out of cities
yeah we certainly don't want people
living in cities and now they're like oh
there could be a nuclear strike it seems
like they really don't want you there
yeah
you know i know especially when that's
the psa that they're making
hi yeah come skateboard need
blackberries with us now sure
but i will mention as much as you want
to avoid all that fallout there is the
possibility that if you get too much
fallout you'll turn into a ghoul now
ghouls are disfigured but they are
immortal that's true
and special treatment
yeah
free college going to college
got a good thing it's a fallout
reference for those that are not
familiar with what are you talking about
i love the fallout series man it's so
good oh yeah
all right jason lindholm says amerv has
multiple warheads like one warhead could
hit all five boroughs at once plus any
any military industrial targets the same
time watch first strike the old dock on
the cold war strategy out crazy
the chronicles of chris says didn't
russia help rebuild buildings that
america bombed in afghanistan
oh
here we go
chase understands chase borges says the
nuclear warning is in case one of
pelosi's swimsuit
[Laughter]
and tops of those icb milkers falls out
chase chase chase chase
inappropriately this could take out at
least brooklyn yeah get inside get
inside
oh man that was awful
okay okay now there's a whole bunch of
nancy pelosi super chats like a stay
puft marshmallow man when he cooks
oh man
all right carlos caballero
caballero says hi tim and crew
unfortunately i've been really
struggling to pay for my dog bon bon
he's very sick and have given everything
i have for him any help would greatly
appreciate at bon bon's medical expenses
go fund me let me write that down
bon bon hang in there dude it's so i i i
lost a cat over uh kovid and i like
still think about him uh i i hate my
iphone memories are like hey you
remember your ex and dead
um and so it's really hard and like um i
mean people are pretty cool about it now
but i mean it
you know that there are some
ghouls who that don't like uh animals
we'll just be like oh it's just a pet or
whatever i hate those people dude it it
it's so hard so hang in there too like i
know you're trying to take care of your
guy but make sure you're taking care of
yourself too
paul socorro says when can i get a dave
landau stand-up special on timcast.com
i mean she's like monday through
thursday on crowder yeah
are you special um we shot one in dallas
but i don't know if i'm going to put it
out because i'm just i'm just anal
like i wanna
no it's funny it's it's it's very funny
i just want to make it different i look
fat
oh i'm there it is you know what you
know what we should just edit it to make
you really skinny instead yeah and make
me look great make me look ripped to the
point that it's obnoxious how obviously
cgi it is like angley's hulk how long is
it awesome
uh well we did we taped like an hour and
a half but i probably cut it down to
about 50. 50 minutes yeah and how many
frames per second 24
i have no idea so we shot at an old
wheelie camera what we'll do is 24
frames per second gotcha 50 minutes okay
so 50 times 60 we got a lot of frames to
go through but we'll use you ever see
the face app handsome a fake
handsomification thing they do
every single frame you'll just be you're
like you know that you know the chad
meme with the guy with a really big [ __ ]
yeah
we'll just do that would you make me
bruce campbell
like you'll be lifting weights for your
closer yeah what's he doing no i think
i'm going to put it out we're just kind
of editing it around and depending on
who wants to buy because we've had two
different offers so it just depends on
that and then we'll put it what's what's
a comedy special like i know dave
chappelle gets tens of millions of
dollars oh yeah it's not going to be
like that it'll be but it'll be decent
you know like make a living does it like
you buy a ferrari or something oh yeah i
could i could
you know i could pay off a house in
detroit so i mean
i mean it's upwards at least one dollar
it's ten dollars it's upwards of three
figures my friends
the low end of three figures yeah well i
mean i'm not saying rich
i could buy 600 in detroit or uh gary
indiana i think yeah
i could buy the old jackson five houses
i don't i don't feel bad for making fun
of detroit but i do feel bad for making
fun of gary indiana yeah well yeah
because detroit you know people still
want to live there
oh it's so cool
no well i mean have you been to gary
i've been through i've heard i've heard
a tail yeah most people get off a gear
and they go i gotta use the bathroom for
chicago and they're like i'll just i'll
just urinate all over my car
[Laughter]
all right
andrew osler says tim big fan for super
chat love dave landau he has been such a
fantastic addition to louder with
crowder also the apple doesn't fall far
from the tree this is what we know about
hunter what has joe been up to in the
last 50 years
yeah
yeah you know joe budden is a great man
and hunter biden is not so i have to
imagine that anything hunter does joe
biden does tenfold yes so 30 hookers
300 yeah easy
joe he's got all the ladies like come on
man
yeah like
hunter lets him leave
[Laughter]
joe doesn't need to cross state lines
because they're all in the white house
basement that's true
they don't go anywhere they just go the
only place they go six feet downward
nathan harrison says they want to scare
you into support for ukraine with that
psa they want you to believe that if
ukraine loses then the u.s is next i
think so that was one of the first
things i thought
scare fear porn that russia is going to
be like let's nuke new york city
yeah like why put that in people's heads
i mean i guess i understand if
you think that if people are
everything's gonna be fine if ducking
inside a building if that happens like
plan for the next nine months if
something like that happens start by
getting out of a city if something like
that happens you shouldn't be in a city
to begin with
civilization two is an awesome game
it's like back in the 90s i just played
all the time when i was a kid and now
just like nuke everyone
that was the gandhi it was a bug in the
game where if you ever had a treaty with
gandhi and you betrayed the treaty he
just nuked you and never stopped nuking
you and the bug was so funny that they
left it throughout the game that gandhi
will go insane no but any any world
leader in civilization can have various
traits aggressive peaceful whatever but
i would always just like i'd play to the
point where i was done playing and then
i would just mass produce nukes and just
send them all off and just and it's like
what happens is a bunch of skulls start
appearing everywhere in the ground
because your radioactive waste is
everywhere and then global warming
happens and then every like cities
crumble and roads collapse if your
opponents have foolishly built cities on
the water those cities go under when you
start launching the nukes wasn't there
there was a funny story where a guy said
he was like he had played the game for
like a decade civilization two and he
was on like the year 5000 or something
because he just like had always played
the game since he was young and just
always would reload the save and the
whole world was just people constantly
nuking each other and everything was
wiped out except for the ability to
build nukes
and then once
yeah yeah it's completely accurate
but
the funny thing about those games is
that they don't they can only have us
they can all have technology in them
that we know about so like there's
technology in the latest version of
silver is like seven or six six
six has technological advancements that
two obviously doesn't have because it's
been 30 years almost so it's it's funny
to see how different it'll become you
know
but they just kind of stop so like for a
game that goes on for a thousand years
it's like yeah if we never developed any
new technology outside of this now we've
got crazy like laser weapons do you guys
know the laser-induced plasma channel is
no
they i guess they gave up on this but
the idea was
how do you look
like hm right no i'm in the military
right yeah and
you know i see jamie's over there
and i want to strike him with lightning
ah man so what do i do to make that
happen yeah i figured it out how about
talk it out they figured it out what
you're doing no no you use a very
powerful infrared laser which
superheats it ionizes the air oh come on
man creating a channel that electricity
can travel through the path
so they could point it at you
and then when they when they pull the
trigger it flickers this laser and then
the electricity instantly because it's
overcharged just bam whenever it's
pointed at all right super cool weapon
it's an electro shock but it just like
crushes your insides oh no lights like
it burns you from the inside like a bulk
guys now the upside is it's not all it's
not all downsides it sounds really damn
upside is you can use an electrolaser to
send hydrogen from saturn into the sun
and sustain the being and on people you
don't like all right
that's right
there's also really small versions they
make what a fun weapon
you know how quickly you get in line
somebody made a door
yes they made a door that has a whole
bunch of small laser-induced plasma
channels yeah so it's constantly just
you can see arcs of electricity
flickering it's basically creating like
a
walk through this and get shocked thing
you know like you don't want to walk
through it
whoa yeah then i remember like command
and conquer remember the tesla coils
yeah that was the first time i'd heard
of them i didn't i didn't even know
tesla was a real guy until i saw the
video game was like wow this is a neat
fantasy they're television
electrocutes you and kills you i was
much happier when the only video game i
remembered was duck hunt i know you know
if you take that late that's a gun yeah
yeah an ass gun and you point it at the
bottom of the screen right up on the
screen you pull the trigger it kills any
duck anywhere
no try it out get a nintendo try the
originals yep the original one it's all
you had to do because none of them
actually worked you'd be sitting there
pointing at the duck angry
how did it actually work like it didn't
[Laughter]
know i mean in the 1986 one when we got
it like for the first time
it did not yeah i swear it didn't work
when i had it it worked you'd point it
to the duck and pull the trigger and it
would work and i guess the idea was that
it took a picture of it or something oh
okay i'm looking it up now yeah that's
crazy how did that work and i wonder
like i think our tv was just whatever
what if you what if you took a another
tv and paused it
and then whenever the duck popped up you
just shut the pause to one and it would
kill the live one oh my goodness i'm
gonna try that out i bought duck
oh i don't have the blaster though gotta
get the blaster the zapper the zapper
we got sword and scale with a massive
super chat yo shout out sword and scale
really appreciate it saying dave dave
landau and tim poole is one hell of a
pairing please do this again also please
tell dave i can't wait to see him in
houston in september at the smart
financial center awesome thank you dude
i love sword and scale and update we
teespring does have onesies
contacting me about it sorry bad news
the onesies are the only ones made by
child slaves
they thought it would be ironic so yeah
that's actually not true buy the onesies
buy the onesies and i guess i guess
we'll make the step one
snakes on its way so keep your eyes on
the prize that's awesome we'll set like
12 of them
all right
mookie says the psa nuclear tech was all
wrong
start with getting flat on the ground
the emp will mean you lose all
electronics please don't believe these
people
oh well we have a faraday cage
oh i'm not supposed to tell people am i
no you're not what the heck
so uh we have a faraday cage we have we
actually have a bunch of them
and you know what that does like the mp
when it hits it's a it's a it like
blocks the frequencies from going inside
yeah
they're microwaves we have a bunch of
them
yeah my new jabber rules
put your cell phone in a microwave yeah
i know that in case like the feds
oh no no no no no you don't actually
sell like a movie yeah in a movie so if
if there's a weak emp
you can put stuff in a microwave to
protect them really yeah
so like preppers will will like light
light preppers will just bury a
microwave with like some phones and
batteries and emergency stuff in it that
they would want to use after you know
the apocalypse or whatever yeah or the
big flare from the sun comes
but you need like people to understand
i've been i've been in an actual
research faraday cage before
powerful enough signals can get through
it you need to like multi-layer it if
you really want to protect yourself from
like a nuclear emp i feel like if there
was an attack and i was still friends
with my old friends and i'd be like hey
what are we going to do and they'd be
like cancel chris pratt
that's not fun
ladies and gentlemen
we are going to record the tim cast
after hours so if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and head over to timcast.com
sign up to become a member at about 11
p.m we're gonna upload the after hours
show with dave here it's gonna be a
blast so check that one out you can
follow the show at tim cast irl you can
follow me personally at tim cast dave do
you want to shout anything out uh yeah
shout out to everybody listens louder
than loud with crowder and also uh
please come to the columbus funny bone
this weekend i will be there and uh yeah
davelando.com um and uh yeah that's
about it right on uh dave you're really
funny dude thank you sir it's nice to
finally meet you yeah yeah i'm gonna
start listening to crowder i guess um
yeah if you want to know uh
i will be in uh houston dayton austin
and la you can follow me on twitter at
jamie hilstein i am not kissing up i
have had the most fun it's so nice to
have funny fans again i've legitimately
had fun interacting with you guys so
follow me on twitter at jamiekillstein
on instagram at the jaime killstein
check out cast castle and all the stuff
we're doing we're gonna be going back
into story mode uh i think in like a day
or two um and it's gonna continue i am
now here i live here and then i also
have a podcast a f-ups guide to the
universe which you can get uh just
search it on spotify or itunes or go to
jammykillsteampodcast.com
i read a little bit about the zapper
it's just a little too complex to try
and uh explain right now i think it does
take a picture of these these flashes on
the screen and then tells the gun which
one did it aim at but hey let me tell
you something i do know
king trip
launched a hilarious uh
i guess
a parody parody yeah i think so of our
episode with chloe carmichael and it's
on his his youtube channel it's it's
extreme i've watched it like five or six
times so far just for the little moments
that i keep crying with laughter is
hilarious so check that out if you want
to follow me ian crossland.net get
through there to any one of my social
media accounts and hit me up there see
you later if you guys do want to check
out that ping trip video it's p1ng
ping trip and he has a youtube channel
and yeah we're on there with dr chloe
carmichael i need to send that to her i
bet she would find that she saw it yeah
she commented on it that's awesome good
for her she's a great great guest as
were you dave as are you always jamie
for sure hilarious gentlemen good
evening um and thank you guys uh for
watching this evening and you guys can
follow me on twitter at mines.com at
sourpatchlids as well as patchlets.me
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com you don't want to miss it
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you